peu
[Musique]
allez
au bout
[Musique]
c'est beau mais rod et toi mais romero
veux tu te tais merci papa travaille ses
impulsions
[Musique]
m
alors oui ah oui c'est toi oui bonjour
ma chérie mais non lotie valettois phone
mais combien de fois des prix et la
bataille fait rage entre 9h et 12h tu
sais bien que ton père travaillait bat
entendu divers toujours des jeunes et le
mal bien sûr une chronologie qu avec qui
elle a pas question je refuse de deux
garçons maintien chez moi quand même dit
que l'on me propose et tmh à ma petite
fille tu couches avec qui tu veux mais
vous leur imposez à ta mère la présence
d'un soi-disant étudiant en sociologie
qui l'a prêté en pleine table de mal
baisées ne serait ce que vis à vis de
ton père je trouve que halo elle a
raccroché alexis mexique
je regrette annoncé que ta fille n'y a
pas les gêner le main j'aimerais qu'on
parlait des trajets support rien tu n'es
jamais pour la fille est vraiment trop
mal élevés la faute à qui à l'époque
ouais enfin j'aimerais bien avoir une
face tant sa rencontre avec cet individu
qu'ils osent émettre été enfreinte à
lyon sinon je revenais marmonnait il a
dit non s'embarrasser pas que j'ai
entendu formaliseront peu trop mais bien
de nous deux ce n'est pas moi la prison
assure t il me semble oui je suis
d'accord avec toi ce jeune homme de
saint pandelon fils idéal mais dieu
merci carole est contre le mariage elle
est heureuse heureuse avait d'avoir
raison voilà tout cela stimule de me
contrer mais rassure toi quand elle aura
besoin d'argent
elle n'hésitera pas à me retrouver comme
chaque fois et tu te seras taper avec
bonheur son monde donc je m'exécute
aussi de mon côté et naoui cet égard
cette jeunesse le des écoutes ça ne veut
rien à [ __ ] 50k rigoler et 4 trop gay
c'est un village aussi paisible que le
nôtre il paraît qu'une bande de voyous
attaqué la poste ils ont ligoté loisel
des passages chez les fils téléphoniques
voler l'argent des pavés tous les
mandats comme chedjou n'aurait pas mon
vieux les surprenne autre genre gamin de
5 ans qui faisait des descentes scène
sur le mur du garage
si j'étais au gouvernement je te fiche
mon billet que réfé de contestation dans
les maternelles
quand les rétifs au monde dans les
minutes à ça ne sera pas longue notre
doux pays monde mine de se bat en
creusant bien alors fait les bras assez
mignon carole mais je compte sur toi
pour dire à ta première occase même pas
cautionner nullement l'attend sur le
prendre parti laisse moins d'heures ne
pas croire deux parties ça pour être est
allé filmer ça fait un équilibre avec la
tienne qui serait plus dont je fonce et
celle avec la première mais souvent
portée des formes ont tissé je sais pas
d'identité entendu avec zimmermann pour
cette série de concerts on ne négocie
twelve ou même pas que j'accepte comme
fallu premier coup tout ce que ce
paradis de jean hermann me propose pour
10 dons pour vos sièges du lait ce gala
châtel guyon ans adjoint de birima aucun
prix mais aussi bien de ses intestins
qui gargouille
ce va-et-vient perpétuel entre la salle
et les toilettes quand leurs shoots la
musique concrète avec un gaz accepté mon
papy dis oui je dis toujours roulé a
précédemment à dire non avant quelque
chose comme c'est facile qui m'ont fait
jouer un rôle
comment cette année après ça si j'ai la
réputation d'être une terreur réputation
que tu entretiens joyeusement cette
grise devenir non d'envoyer au bas d'un
lâcher aux gens leurs quatre vieilles
j'ai mon franc parler mais quand jean
brajon poignarde pas dans le dos ah oui
ceinture embrassera rom et un coup de
poignard facile pourquoi tu si intense
exigeant pourquoi tu as tu as tout en
apportant tout est important un nom
justement faut savoir flotter quelques
fois élu dé fermer les yeux et nous la
grande rencontre est allé ce que je les
écarte il faut mieux dans les choses en
face et des joueurs se fera toujours
souhaité à tous évidemment du one flew
le prince des courants d'air on va
l'autre jour quel besoin habitude de
dire à gibert match qu'elle était une
planche pourrie même si fort ikapi de
planches
ou enfin ce journal unités dans les
choses pour les rapports à meteghan être
critiqué détester toi tu as besoin de
plaire d'être aimé par tout le monde où
l'on coupe du monde par quelques-uns
dans mes amis il a des amis tu vas parle
beaucoup mais quel effort fais tu pour
entretenir l'amitié
jamais tu n'auras qu'aux téléphones et
s'ils n'étaient pas là pour le faire
jamais tu te répondre à une lettre non
dans le fond d'une vie que pour ton
violoncelle je vous en supplie mon fils
ils ont mon vieux ne viendra me dire que
c'est moins que tu as fait tes amis
enfin d'idron savez bien en plus à mon
avis sonia garrigue palma passe très
bien
pas toujours eu un regard d'emmener mes
15 ans et un de mes plus vieux copain
comme frédéric alphonse cela aussi je
les aperçois plus que deux grands -
concert quand je pense que pendant des
années nous avons passé toutes nos
vacances à ces aigris ça l'est pas et
qui regrettent cet achat n'est ce pas
non non je trouve un seydou contraire de
tout ce virus pourquoi vieillit rajeunir
à la rigueur il est vrai qu avec l
impression que tagliani compte double
non crois moi tu n'as plus rien en
commun avec ce petit groupe
et puis plus rien n'a jamais c'était
comme avoir depuis que tu as fait c'est
embrouillé avec sa vigne à prendre j'ai
dit qu'elle était une [ __ ] heures
pourquoi ce que jeanne ne nous
pardonnerait pas à nos fils qui le lui
pardonnent yanaëlle rock à l'hypocrite
celui-là il a certainement des problèmes
sexuels
je suis surtout content je suis sûr
qu'elle est impuissante à douala tu sais
que c'est là sans doute entend dire du
mal de tout le monde en longueur rejoint
ne lis pas mal ça m'est égal mois que
sabine fait une [ __ ] je ne la juge pas
je constate un fait sabine est une
[ __ ] oui on sait que tu sais et pour
cause alors tout ça parce que je suis
sorti deux ou trois fois avec eux
pendant que des deux agences 12 avec ta
fierté mon chéri la différence entre
nous c'est que je m'affiche des autres
moi je t'ai puis ça me suffit je connais
ta soif d'absolu mais tout de même a de
toute façon ça ne te déplaît pas à
défaut sans victime une fois pour toutes
je suis le cerbère la marâtre la
pétroleuse étoiles vont type d'artiste
le doux rêveur martyrisé par sa fille de
bonne famille si je comprends bien tu
fais tout ça pour me protéger
naturellement que florès je ne vais pas
tuer mongori de chats merci dans chéri
non
thomas kaiser il ya une journaliste qui
vient d'interviewer pour marit le niveau
non aussi justement tu tenais la tirade
ce magazine marie claudine tu veux que
je faire du site jean rapenne ans des
milliers de lectrices c'est à dire ton
public se dépense publique là qui
m'intéressent unique est bon à prendre
moment qu'ils payent faisaient dans les
banques est alors pas de quatrième ronde
puisque tu connais importance de tous
enfin c'est égal j'aurais bien aimé
passer mon week-end tranquille une fois
que l'amour à papy la pauvre fille ça
fait 80 km pour un quart d'heure
d'entretien avec toi un samedi matin par
la porte de la chapelle et bah c'est pas
de la tarte
le à raison j'y tiens je te promet de
répondre est aimablement question cette
planète va faire un grand numéro de
charme comme d'habitude tu as vu ce
soleil
j'ai les mêmes vices élevé ça sent l'été
tiens tu sais pourquoi si on prenait
nous venons pour faire une balade dans
les bois cet après-midi faut d'abord que
le thaï la lotus mais un potager c'est
exigeant le jardinier qui vient situe
pas sur son dos et il sait rien de la
journée une personne ne fiche rien côté
toi tu n'arrêtes pas qu'est ce que tu
fais depuis culv et moi que je ne le
proposait le bab et j'ai réparé la
tondeuse les gravillons ou 10 risqué
pour arracher aux étourneaux les
dernières cerise
je vais faire à l'autre vie j'ai skié
quelques bûches quoi encore l'armoire
l'hormone qui encombraient le palier va
maintenant les tout premiers jeux la
déménager sur ton dos et épais devait
démontrer d'abord et après je librement
et tout ça dans une même matinée madame
et ça ne suffit pas encore que tu portes
classiques que du grinçant ça me repose
à quoi servent les blancs fil blanc
commence à les virer
parlons bons éléments enfin la valeur
vient pourtant bien se souvient au fur
et après notre bavarde avec sa
petite-fille majorettes et sa descente
d'organes même temps etc tourner
cet accord est le second des tribuns peu
mais bien de faire tout ça là tu me tues
bilan c'est pas tout ça me fait penser
au déjeuner - je te propose des rôles à
l'oseille 20 jeunes souffrent sur 73
tandis que pour abc culte et c'est ma
véhicule elle en a vu d'autres et j'en
ai tellement envie que ça peut pas me
faire de mal
mais un jour ça toujours enceinte
magnifiques gambettes
si on aperçoit ta journalistes des
jeunes ouailles et bien allons-y pour le
déconnage et ben droit jamais aussi bien
dans cette mégapole est à la campagne à
l'amour d'engagement 20 km de lausanne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
excusez moi mais originaux et je ne vous
avais pas entendu entrée oui je ne
savais pas je suis confuse de vous
arracher à luis borges en nous
retrouvant souvent oui j'imagine oui
paul il avait du magazine marie claudine
vous entendrez nombreux jeunes vous sera
tout je vous en prie un sim non là sur
le canapé oui ou s'appeler bonfoh retard
vous voulez gérer voir quelque chose est
bien barrabes ont très peu de
journalistes sont unis si vous savez oui
ça ma retraite mater vahid mont
grand-fonds malan kia mais j'ai voulu
faire une exception pour marie claude
lienhard it
bienvenue donc aux moulins merci m et
que vous le voyez c'est une vieille
bâtisse sans grand intérêt mais à ces
normes dans sa rusticité
oui je me sens bien j'aime j'aime cette
campagne française oui tous les matins
j'ouvre ma fenêtre et je suis devant un
tableau de monet loin des rumeurs de la
ville non pas qu'il y règne ici le calme
qu'on voit et poireaux entre les quatre
les chiens les tracteurs et mes pires
ennemis les cyclos batteur le silence
deschamps fait un bruit d'enfer mais
j'ai retrouvé la paix intérieure et sera
pour un artiste le principal
vous ne pensez pas il faut dire aussi
que je ne sens auditif particulièrement
sensible lors de ma dernière tournée en
union soviétique
imaginez vous qu'un soir à moscou alors
tu veux que je regagnais volontaire à
pied j'ai cru percevoir mais très
distinctement le son dans la neige
tombant sur 29 vraiment oui le but
j'avais raconté cette anecdote à
rostropovitch
oui oui qui l'on n'était pas étonné du
tout lui-même lui-même affirmé qu'il
m'est arrivé d'entendre glisser des
nuages comme c'est intéressant le sport
le tout petit garçon j'ai écouté pendant
des heures le bruit du vent dans les
fils électriques je connais mon leurs
règles poteau un jeu repose un joli
temps d'orage fée maléfique la plus
belle symphonie que j'aie jamais
entendue la fourrure la foudre tombe à
tout prix je manquais d'être électrocuté
mais ma vocation était décidé rien
oui je serai musiciens mais je me
permets de vous signaler ma boizel que
l'anecdote et il est dit oui et cela
pour une bonne raison c'est que je viens
de l'inventer
[Rires]
bon mais bien vous pourrez toujours vous
en servir pour votre papier c'est vrai
cela bien évidemment chat c'est à dire
que moi vous n'avez pas l'air à l'aise
du tout et ce que je vous intime et non
mais bon alors je vous assure voyons
donc ça j'avoue j'en suis il vient de
passer ne me donnait pas du même genre
comme ça
enfin je ne sais plus quoi faire pour
vous sortir de votre mutisme en moyenne
vous avez peut-être oui vous avez
peut-être une question posée
oui oui bon mais bien leur poser là vous
pourrez lavit d'abdel vous soyez
charmante c'est moi qui veut ça m'ennuie
pas
est ce que madame breuker et là ma
famille je crois parce que c'est elle
que je suis venu interviewer oui m je
crains qu'il n'ait eu un malentendu
content de l'iphone j'avais bien précisé
madame merkel je n'en doute pas mais moi
j'aime mon enfant règle générale c'est
un mois que la presse en terre elle se
passe dans ma femme d'où la confusion et
justement les lectrices ont un peu assez
de lire toujours la même chose sur les
mêmes jours et bien je m'en voudrais de
races et les lectrices peuvent
maintenant j'en sais pas ce que j'ai
voulu dire si derrière moi jamais mais
qu'est ce que vous savez nous poser
comme question à ma femme non journal
fait une enquête sur les femmes qui
vivent dans l'ombre des grands artistes
celle qui se dévouent et ses farces les
obscurs les obscurs
alors là celle-là vous ne pouvait pas
mieux tomber avec marié oui je voulais
faire je vous rappelle mario mario voit
pas la rive
j'espère m'être que vous ne m'en voulez
pas franchement je vous avoir fait
perdre votre temps je n'ai pas peur mais
quelle drôle d'idée cette enquête tout
de même vous trouvez vous ne faites pas
partie du mlf mon journal n'est pas du
tout dans ces idées là non
nous prônons encore marie claudine et
très réactionnaire il n'empêche pas
devant les convictions personnelles sur
ce sujet je me méfie des femmes quand
les convictions personnelles et qui se
fait du bien il faut dire que vous ne
m'avez guère laissé l'occasion de placer
un mot oui excusez moi il habitude de
celui-ci apprécier nos mieux benoît ce
fait mérite reconnaissance canadienne
abacha tombe bien parce que justement
c'est toi qu'elle vient vers vous et mac
est là mais moi je ne m'intéresse pas du
tout on a ajouté par la confusion m mais
que les problèmes que c'est pour vous
que je suis là tel rêve idée mais je
n'existe pas un an je ne suis rien et
vous êtes la femme d'alexis brucker et
c'est à ce titre que vous prenez place
dans nos galeries de portraits et
beaucoup de leurs mais franchement leur
guerre l'intérêt en dessous des méfaits
toute cette route
eh bien je te laisse son free savais que
c'était mal père sera laissée comme une
fois d'esprit et ne pas laisser traîner
ton instrument et côte on restait 2 buts
et 2 dans l'autre jour j est arrivé de
justesse pour empêcher le chialeux lever
la patte dessus allez prendre à ça
il rentre vite dans sa voix à des gens
mérite il faut ce qu il est en contrat
avec la flûtiste navigue pas les
couilles véritable calvaire elle va vous
raconter sa venue la paix c'est
merveilleux cette complicité entre vous
deux devrait on s'entend bien
alors pas encore comment mon nom qu'elle
s'intitule mon mari est un homme célèbre
j'ai l'intention de traiter des
inévitables problèmes du couple dans une
situation de ce genre emblème quel est
le problème et il n'y a t'il pas dualité
entre vos aspirations personnelles il
roulait fausse et que vous tenez n'en
attendaient que je réfléchisse se bat
faut maintenant parce que je ne me suis
jamais posé la question qui est d'une
marion breuker je suis marion bruckert
n'est chastagnol nationalité française
tard hier mais de 71 x 57 kg signe
particulier n'ait ans
c'est passionnant anglais continue il me
semble que vous vu minimiser que nous
voulions ou non votre personnalité
classe avait surtout la mecque j'ai pris
trois kilos le mois dernier franchement
beau mettre au régime
ces fringales et reichstett pas
justement il s'appelle frustration
chocolat ils sont interdits à bord d'un
véhicule mis à part les chocolats en
avez vous renoncé à rien et qu'ils vont
pas doué pour quelque chose
si vous n'arrivez pas à écouter monsieur
bruyckere qu'auriez vous souhaitez faire
un scaphandrier notamment rêve de petite
fille
je suis sûr vous en auriez tk par hélas
alex une fois pas de violence trêve de
plaisanterie mais ne briguait pas les
hommes de randy un talent quelques mots
que j'ai très mal en point n'est besoin
de marquer mon violon d'ingres c'est mon
violoncelliste voilà je nie mauges les
notes vous considérez donc comme une
femme comblée en neige pas l'air ma foi
si donc selon vous le bonheur conjugal
est un choix valable une fin en soi très
bonnes odeurs le bonheur c'est beau la
wii wheel échappatoire et bien tout ça
beaucoup trop compliqué pour moi voilà
et l'orgasme
on part dans ce qu'il percevait très
nouveau exactement dans le contexte des
relations un peu peur des postes dans la
recette de mon souffle et à la barbe
il est extra je suis sûr que ce sera au
choix un très bel extraordinaire celle
ci ne sont pas de mon ressort nous avons
une rubrique spéciale libertin amélie ne
l'attendait pourtant amélie est ce que
je me trompe
l'impression que vous essayez d'élus des
robots comprenez madame manage our évita
s'il voit un profil psychologique sans
concession on va mon ambition c'est
d'aller plus loin un petit jeu l'homme
nommé ce que d'aller trop loin
je ne demande pas mieux de ne payer
votre interview mais franchement je suis
incapable de répondre à tous tes âneries
mais pourtant madame j'ai collaboré à
van der nouvel observateur avons en
direct en alarme demandé comme ça de but
en blanc ce que pensent de l'orgasme
honnêtement mais maintenant vous avez
vous réponds c'est la question que nous
sommes toutes concernées qui a donné des
tables rondes des meetings des défilés
n'est pas moi ça me laisse froid à la
voix si je me dis et vous m'ont dit ça
va te coûter la face à valence et vous
êtes jeunes vous êtes dans le vent c'est
le genre de questions auxquelles vous
devez savoir répondre je ne suis pas
embarrasser le moins du monde irait pas
barrée par des femmes à la vie ce n'est
pas moi qui suis interview eh bien
faisons comme si c'était vous allez là
permettez moi de vous féliciter et
pourtant je vous trouve bien crise fait
il n'y a pas là je vous en prie madame
ses sens et je n'encaisse que vous
prendre la forme loisel je n'ai pas
voulu me moquer de vous
quelquefois quand je plaisante je mets
mes gros sabots mon mari me le reproche
souvent mais là j'ai vraiment pas ce que
je peux dire vous êtes hyper s'est aussi
excusé moi je suis grand manan vous vous
énervez pas cependant des craintes que
votre interview sera un fiasco que vous
ne pouvez rien tiré le moi je rien
d'intéressant à dire n'a aucun rapport
avec notre interview je ne comprends pas
je vais tout vous expliquer moi pas trop
longs mademoiselle parce que j'aime mon
oreillette sur le feu vous devez prendre
pour une folle n'est ce pas un modèle de
nos jours qui est normal lorsque la
rédactrice en chef mais qu'ils doivent
il m'a proposé ce reportage
je lui dis je ne suis pas en condition
physique de mener à bien cette enquête
mais elle elle a pensé que ça me change
les idées à leurs résultats et comme ces
bêtes de ne pas pouvoir se contrôler
pendant quinze jours je n'ai pas arrêté
de pleurer ma faim pourquoi donc bien
d'avoir une raison aux ragots des mois
ça m'amuserait temps intéresse vous avez
des chagrins d'amour ça n'est pas volée
tombée sur un petit muscle journalistes
ou photographes et un ingénieur en
électronique ça fait sérieux est ce
important point de mieux mais sérieux
alors nous devions partir ensemble pour
celles c'est paradisiaque c'est leurs
ébats il est parti tout seul pour
quiberon
car le toit non la cure alors viala
quiberon vous va vous désespérez il en
est revenu justement avec une
kinésithérapeute de fermer les yeux non
non non non non je ne veux pas revoir
ailleurs intellectuellement l'écart
entre nous était trop ce cas vous avez
raison aux merlus oublier si je le
pouvais il n'empêche pas complètement
démoli à cause de lui j'ai fait une
dépression mérité certes pas comme vous
voyez je ne suis pas complètement remise
puisque je me donne si ridiculement
spectacle devant que maintenant je suis
là pour ça ainsi vous saviez comme je
m'en veux et aussi peu maîtresse de moi
même mon psychanalyste avant si vous
faites chez canaliser en plus oui
après ma première tentative de suicide
peggy m'envoyer de force chez les
professeurs borg vous connaissez votre
réputation bien humainement c'est un
homme remarquable assez séduisant je
dois dit célibataire homosexuel ont su
débusquer rien contre admettez manon
plus maintenant comme le votez pas fait
pour me remonter le moral
donc mon psy calais ce jeudi je suis à
la merci d'un choc émotionnel que ma
sensibilité est à vif ce qui vous
explique c'est l'âme d'un tampon
pauvreté que la votre prénom
pauline pas folle et il faut réagir oui
oui c'est ce que je me disais métier qui
me passionne qui me permet d'approcher
toutes sortes de gens intéressants qui
ont une vie mais je ne le pardonne et
proposer désabusé d'un beau jeune fille
jeune et belle comme un bon ya pas de
bon vous savez quand votre place on
change de coiffure oh là là mon dieu
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce bonheur
et puis pourquoi ces lunel j'étais dans
les verres de contact faudra apprend à
vendre pour qui l'amour une profession
de foi aussi sorte que définitive faut
sortir le soir voire du monde
j'avoue qu'après une journée de travail
j'ai plutôt tendance à rester devant ma
télé des juifs humeur étaient des gifles
si vous étiez ma fille j'ai pas
tellement bien réussi de ce côté là non
et assez parlé de moi même j'ai encore
quelques questions à vous voulez vous
que nous reprenions notre petit
entretien je n'en vois pas l'utilité
aborder ce que vous voudrez chaussures
me vendait très bien
or s'il est vrai que j'ai bien dû vous
ennuyer avec toutes mes histoires
absolument battre très sympathique
quant à moi madame marion soit marion
merci m'avoir écouté avec autant de
compréhension est-ce que je peux me
permettre de vous téléphoner le jaune
entre lover et michelin naturellement je
soumettrai l'article que je vais essayer
d'écrire si on vous je veux que vous en
soyez satis n'arrêtait pas moyen de
faire passer une photo d'alexis et voilà
justement la liste de ses prochains
concerts
si vous pouviez la glisse est comme ça
incidemment oui mais je ferai de mon
mieux peut-être même taille que voilà un
rappeur mario revoir mon petit 1 vous
êtes une femme pharma cascal [ __ ]
croyez où je puisse saluer monsieur
roquet avant de partir il m'a reçue si
gentil mais assure alexis marie claudine
me dérange mais ne travaille pas s'ils
travaillaient entendre voilà ça s'est
bien passé nous a vidé son sac sur l'a9
ça ne m'a pas parlé des toilettes allait
plaire je vais vous parler ça le regarde
n'est ce pas pauline à tout ce que je
peux vous dire mais c'est que je sors
d'ici cinq ans il y avait bien les
choses de la vie grâce à madame rock'n
roll de la banlieue alors tu vois tu
rien on mais il me reste plus qu'à
prendre un congé
et alors ça devrait être abolie de ce
fait mais ça s'est fait comme ça vient
de la bouscule pas marion j'ai vu un
gendre il est formidable et maintenant
je vous laisse à vos retours voir ou
revoir mais il est vrai qu est ce que tu
lui as fait qu'est ce que tu lui as dit
pourquoi voilà laissent subjuguer par
toi-même arrigans vallespir et la
sympathie face au vent mais quelquefois
quand même la presse n'a pas de chance
ce genre de fille sous ce que je ne vois
pas de support moyenne assez touchés
elle est complètement paumé ont encore
toutes les mêmes et le crâne elles ont
l'air à vous juger du haut de leur
grandeur et dans le fond elles savent
pas du tout une chanson sur ce jeu
mettra qui en lozère parce que t'es pas
tout simplement
alors d'accord moi je lui fais confiance
pour les non non mais imaginez vous que
ensuite robert une fausse manoeuvre j'ai
mordu sur le bas-côté leurs bestiaux tu
me suis pas rendu compte de la
profondeur du fossé n'est pas blessé au
moins mais non non non non gelée très
doucement heureusement il est possible
de sortir la voiture de là tout ça a dit
alex laval accueillera de la jv avec une
disqueuse mois que j'ai pas besoin de
toi permettent sur ses quatre roues
manhattan
je crois que ce ne soit pas possible
marionnaud si je suis venu me déranger
si pour lui demander la permission de
téléphonie à un garage faster lundi va
vous rêvez ou des jeunes en france on
dit mais quoi faire quand même que des
jeunes allez vous rester avec nous mais
certainement pas égratigné par un café
dans ce pays où je pour attendre
l'ouverture du terrain avec la ville
alexis de la nuit on ne discute pas les
genres dont le sait pas de raisons pour
vous asseoir le déjeuner reste à faire
ou à laisser
carré d'herbe le cueillir à brader ce
sera donc pour la salade
le staff et on dise ne souffrira pas
trop quand tu as connu
comment puis-je me rendre utile j'adore
et et la cuisine ça tombe bien la
machine à laver et entamera toute la
vaisselle à faire les lecteurs
pierre aliker à labroquère je voudrais
une fois de plus dans l'obligation
un broker
madame breuker où êtes-vous ici c'est
que monsieur collinet y avait longtemps
macasty se passe encore là il se passe
que je ne suis pas pour autant n'est
jamais content il est vrai qu'avec une
tête comme la banque même si vous voulez
care center ma retraite je le ferais un
terme aux assauts lensois gasquet en
train de lire les codes du mois vous
pouvez pas tomber plus mal
il n'y a que votre chien a encore fait
un trou dans la clôture pour pénétrer
dans mon jardin
non content de piétiner des plans
d'études labour est mon gazon et de
démarches sténopé zulia il tourmente
notre pauvre petite marquise qui est en
chasse à l'examen montchauvet ton métier
de chien monsieur voilà des histoires
pour rien les dents en attendant cela
fait monter la tension de madame
collinaires ait eu mon chien va grimper
ouais mais madame mais surtout c'est
interdit d'aider tout cas c'est la
dernière fois que je vous le rappelle je
les enfermer dans le garage
attention de ne pas le laisser
s'échapper sans votre chienne qui rend
fou mon pauvre néron il est très loin de
ces choses là une fois pour toutes que
jamais unis reviendraient plus sinon je
ne réponds pas des suites que je
donnerais cette affaire je vous prie
instamment de tenir attachez votre boxer
est un fléau public
chacun chez soi ça vous manquez pas de
culot votre antenne de télévision au
tout venant rendre sur les rosiers un
autre toit de tuiles mécaniques cas
france m'a vu les vosges ignoble pigeon
propagateurs de maladies qui viennent
gonfler mes meubles de jardin mais le
ciel est à tout le monde c'est peut-être
le capot de leur voiture après chaque
week-end notre tout moche tel dans ses
excréments
quand j'ai acheté ma carte au 4 l et es
noir dans maintenant l'état poids
c'est d'ailleurs ça me plaît et je vois
qu'il est impossible de discuter avec
une personne d'aussi beaux espoirs
désormais c'est à la gendarmerie que je
m'adresse 500 voiliers mais les
gendarmes quand je manque quand je pense
que madame collines et moi nous nous
sommes retirés à la campagne dans
l'espoir de finir paisiblement le jour
après une vie de labeur et de dignité et
qu'à cause de vous cette retraite est
devenue un enfer n'est que purgatoire
attendais un petit mot culture
mais si si la bagarre de recherche est
valable bolloré et des menaces
vous êtes une bûche ghana
à savoir des bases appareils mais j'ai
pris sur moi
valait pas la peine d'en faire un
incident part dans mon chéri pardon je
sais combien tu es un homme calme et
docks recueillement qui peut retourner
dans ton bureau personnes at elle
rappelé maintenant j'ai des gars il est
bien temps maillot ça ne peut plus durer
comme ça marche dans peuple et de ses
cris de ce film à sion voyait que du
créateur de toi non je finis par en
douter citons paratonnerre ont géré mes
yeux la foudre la vérité c'est que tu
n'as jamais eu mais la campagne je le
vois bien depuis que ça vous installer
au moulin pour l'été titan bet
absolument pas c'est sûrement toi qui me
lève toi tu ne vois pas que je suis le
sud est inquiet bizarre tout cas
plusieurs mois mais qu'est ce qu'ils en
viennent
la cinquantaine ne te feras tu es là
cette fois sa calvitie ce serait l
aggraver ou bien au vieillard est il une
mine est sourd après l'on va justement
ces stèles me disais qu'est ce qui se
passe alexis ne s'intéresserait-il plus
aux minettes maintenir mon avis rien
contre les minettes qui grâce à elle
tutoie toujours chatte vous me la paix
évidemment mon pauvre chéri ce n'est pas
le vieux tableau que je suis qui va
réveiller le jeune amant toi érudit que
je suis mais c'est vrai ça je me
regardais ce matin dans le miroir
grossissant de la salle de bains rôle là
mes enfants qui a déjà une image et bien
ça c'est tout du store vénitien
tu te taire mais quel besoin de te
délivrer ainsi tout ce que tu dis est
complètement fou en plus t'as qui
rêvasse tu en ce moment torres est un
petit élève bulgare de deuxième année
que tu trouves s'il doit pour les plus
de 6 cathy ou alors à la jeune fille des
bureaux de tabac
c'est fou ce que tu vas souvent acheter
le journal depuis quelques jours mais
attend que je ne serai plus qu'un vieux
dragueur qui est en passe de devenir
alexis novembre étant là-bas ça ne fait
rien tu étais très gras bien d'une façon
ou d'une autre il ya chez toi de l'eshop
il suffit que tu veux tu es quelques
créatures de rêve pour qu'aussitôt tu
changes à perceptiblement d'attitude tu
donnes même en période d'incubation les
signes précurseurs aussi évident que la
rougeole ou la scarlatine brut il que tu
m'as observé oui ainsi quand tu te
rappelles yoga quand tu as sorti ton
foulard à la couleur de tes yeux quand
tu t'y nombre de dons de toilette mais
surtout surtout surtout quand tu es
maita conversation de citations
poétiques musset paul eluard alors lie à
pia s'y tromper monsieur est sur le
point de chavirer
monsieur chaville mariant taux extrapolé
bah tant mieux mais si toi mon bonhomme
jeter à lui à fumer je pleure tourner
les obturations 10 dont on déjeune la
police à l'ats c'est elle qui apporte
des jeunes et pour les nombreux invités
avaient tellement serviable et puis
n'oublie pas de suisse entame de ménage
évidemment à toi tu t'en noc dépit des
dons et au 10e gagnent pas beaucoup
pauline depuis qu il est interviewé elle
ne décolle plus du goût là depuis un
mois tous les week-ends on a sur le dos
qu'est ce que tu as contraire son nom
enfin pour quelqu'un d'aussi exigeant
pour bien acheter différentes et 13 ans
que je terrifie tout le monde
en valais il a tout à fait mal à banel
m'adore voilà d'or tout elle adore tout
le monde s'extasie droite est jalouse
dans ce cas mieux que toi
tu sais tu m'intimides beaucoup mais
j'espère bien j'ai pas comme toi il faut
toujours que tu te donnes quelqu'un de
nouveau et avril à ce que je suis déçu
mais que pauline m'a dit ça m'étonnerait
que ça marie n'est pas une bonne raison
c'est que n'en attend pas grand chose je
veux c'est être protégés et a découvert
machine qu'est ce que tu veux aller à
l'air si heureux près de nous ça me
touche au seulement évidemment aller par
madame kurys n'irai pas du tout avec toi
même que c'est aussi ce que je me dis ah
le voilà pourquoi je me contente de poly
encore ce chien tu as dis pas ça me
regarde avec ses dettes à la campagne
les chiens aboient les cantons cocorico
et les kanaks moi je sais pas maintenant
on va contenir des viols rappelle que
son chien
non mais tu l'entends mobile ohlala
milena tout ce n'est pas lui aussi
pourquoi lui aussi j'ai ça comme ça tu
vas pas te prendre pour toi t'es malade
à mon dieu ça va plaire
si le prend pas ces terres excédés je
suis plus au maximum en mariant bonjour
à ses voisines
bonjour c'est pas doubler le rock et le
non jeu les prix dans le contre filet
avec la voix de dieu les palmiers le
sucre roux les feuilles de gélatine la
nouvelle sorbetière evo suppositoire
j'ai dû faire cinq pharmacies je suis
désolé on n'est pas doublé leur ruban
pour la machine à écrire
oh mon dieu je suis catalan seulement la
prochaine fois je l'inscrirai tout quand
on n'a pas de fête faut noter les choses
pour sa tournée doit vous laisser pas
martyriser pour lille marion et après le
temps dans ce home et fanny tout si
j'avais pas les sentiments le rendre un
peu utile
jamais je n'oserais venir ainsi homme-là
c'est ma seule raison d'être ici nous
sommes ravis relève toujours la
bienvenue
n'est ce pas à l'excès rohff n'y avait
pas trop bien sûr l'autoroute tout ça
roulait variétés tout forme et vous
comment s'est passée la semaine il a
fait beau je dois je aller tient
beaucoup travaillé sur scène à 2 500
s'est fait moi j'ai fait des confitures
de groseilles quel merveilleux programme
vous permettront d'évoluer mais qui
devient surprenez vos habitudes faites
comme chez vous ne tardez pas trop ya
les haricots verts a épluché sur les
sent tout de suite que ne s'accompagne
pas vous connaissez votre choix et vous
déranger parce j'ai apporté ma boîte de
peinture
si vous permettez dans l'après midi je
vous avais planté mon chevalet devant le
petit pont je vais essayer de jeter sur
ma toile
toute cette symphonie le faire ça va je
t'échange la toile tout sauf du lot mais
rien que dalle et si c'est un
psychanalyste lui a conseillé de
remettre à la peinture quand supplie
retient après ton esprit critique
oh c'est pas bien que dire des jeunes
parents en 2001 pourquoi j'ai eu le
temps d'ajuster village va faire acheter
des cigarettes encore quand c'est pas le
journal c'est les cigarettes mais si mon
chéri tu as tous les drogba va vers le
joli coeur auprès des fans à un
buraliste
tu sais ce que tu es toi une castratrice
l'aéro la bonne excuse
isa
[Applaudissements]
ta gueule et rouen ce chien oui oui au
cecos le vrai ronaldo ternaire mondial
est passé chez madame bruckert c'est
pour son chien ce qui la laisse amoureux
et ça continue comme ça on va pas fermé
l'oeil de la nuit
bref le docteur bien administré un
sédatif oui bon bon bah je l'expliquerai
aulas n'a pas consulté non plus m
j'adore ma chance l'intrigué n'est ce
pas logique rome jusqu'à ma fenêtre en
beau c'est beau et perrine droit on a
planté pour les 10 ans de ma fille
heureusement qu'elle n'a pas poussé au
30 rue des figurines
j'adore ce prêt donc s'ils désiraient
difficile à portable à grenay vous avez
remarqué y avait de gros nez le grand
espère y avait du monde il est en
goudron brisé bien sable et moi j'adore
en ont assez et il mais c'est vrai ça
avec ces raisons n'ont pas plus ou alors
on en a jusqu'à la fin de l'année
l'urticaire nous adorent et marc berman
d'envoi à tarte aux poireaux vous adorez
les ballets c'est pas possible ça on va
vendre et tout et tout le monde tout le
temps
faut que voulez vous de moi j'ai vu il
aimait tout volé mais rien pas très
gentil ce que vous dit que la mariage en
attribuer la montre au monde java mintsa
celui-là même si bien moi je vais plus
oser rendre la copieuse journaliste
marié votre vocabulaire
tu te déteste ça dégueulasse ça ne va
pas être facile du moins tant je
séjournerai au moulin si vous savez ce
que ça représente pour moi de me
retrouver ainsi dans votre intimité je
considère ça comme un tel privilège
agirait pas et pourtant la vérité allez
c'est un virtuose dans le nord qui
diffèrent seulement célèbre musicien de
génie et et vous pas pesé vos mouvements
une femme de caractère d'une humanité
d'une sensibilité tout à fait
exceptionnel la wii surtout surtout la
sensibilité aléatoire
le formol et au mondial je suis un
chameau donnez-vous tellement habsi
mulet votre vraie nature derrière cette
fausse réputation jeunes dessinent leur
ya de tout ma vraie nature et celle d'un
vrai chameau et la colonie de vacances
des orphelins du violoncelle pour
laquelle vous vous dépenser sans répit
n'est pas le standing d'alexis comme ça
les affaires culturelles le font
toujours passer en premier grâce à ces
affreux chargé décrocher la tournée
d'afrique du sud
c'est faux way c'est l'injustice n'est
pas droit les privilèges c'est au profit
des autres mais pas pour alexine je vois
qu'une autre raison à tout cela c'est
que tout simplement vous avez dit que
mais là je répète que je suis un chameau
mitre bonté pour moi vous avez rendu le
goût le courage de vivre donné à côté
dans le derrière pour vous aider à
repartir voilà tout vient d'orient
risque de vous irriter une fois de plus
que vous soyez un chameau pas moi je
vous adore
cette photo de vous deux qui posait sur
la commode de machault et bain pendant
notre voyage de noces à porquerolles
sadate palier
vous êtes si botul était quelque peu
rayonnant vous formiez vous formez
toujours un peu moins rayonnant
peut-être mais enfin tu es là encore
meurent à boué mais quand je vois tous
les deux je me dis eh bien oui l'amour
5,6 à vous me gênait mais c'est vrai
était encore bien le coup et tous les
deux et vous vous aimez comme au premier
jour
non on différemment et c'est mieux c'est
mon mari est toujours là et ça c'est
l'essentiel
il peut compter sur sa wii comme vous
sur lui dans sa non pas chacun sur
l'emploi moi je farrar le port d'attaché
oui le frère qui est pas du tout alexis
ce serait plutôt notion imprévisible et
fascinante et son côté cela c'est son
côté homme son côté [ __ ] pour ne rien
vous cacher ma chère le m aime la chair
bref il ya des élèves auxquels ils
donnent volontiers des leçons
particulières tenait en ce moment il est
en train de faire du charme à la petite
rousse du bureau d'état comment peut-on
tromper une femme telle que voudront
créer parce que j'ai la tête d'une femme
trophée
non ma sale brive a alors à la seule
dont j'ai vraiment été jalouse c'est la
musique
quand j'ai compris qu alexis lille
sacrifierait tout que je passerai
toujours après eh bien j'ai décidé de
m'effacer et depuis nous avons toujours
fait très bon ménage tous les trois et
vous n'avez jamais été tenté de lui
faire payer ses infidélités lança typage
entre non à maman par exemple cela nous
aurait pas été difficile des tas
d'hommes doit vous faire l'a clos d'un
talent elle est enfin y en a eu et
incertaine et et où alexis avait perdu
la tête pour une shampouineuse je me dis
pourquoi pas alors j'ai sauté le papier
pas si sûr je suis allé au plus rapide
un ami d'alexis un premier viol dont la
petite moustache il était séduisant un
peu trop c'est être un spécialiste de la
chose c'est fou ce que ça m'a rasé et
oui je suis monogame enfants jouent
préférence est maman je préfèrerais
membres ayant l'air
complexe mais que voulez vous on ne se
refait pas à kiel il vous est difficile
d'être une femme humaine
oui je n'aurais jamais cru en dieu jésus
mais qu'est ce qui m'a pris d'aller vous
raconter ça je l'avais oublié moi même
fait en ôtant pauline oublier leur deck
et vous rendez vous l'avez bien
meilleure mine
j'ai suivi mon conseil j'ai changé de
camp toumba drôlement bien des résultats
padam en vue prenez pas de mots plein
vent vaio moulin chaque week-end bien au
contraire mais je me demande si à votre
âge vous n'auriez pas mieux la fibre m
apporter davantage que votre amie à
l'homme par dix et bien justement marion
justement enfin je crois que je suis
amoureuse amoureux mais c'est
merveilleux pour linke s'attendait pour
me dire
or ces 6 récent mais derrière blessures
sont à peine cicatrisées vous faites ici
pourquoi vous n'êtes pas avec lui
ils fassent tous ses week-ends avec sa
femme parce qu'il est marié et là un
homme arrivé décidément vous ne manquez
pas se marier est un vivier décevant
s'il ne divorce pas dans les trois mois
il ya bien que l'espoir pour qu il se
dessine un joli chez deux mois et demi
devant - dia bonne chance mais croyez
moi c'est presque toujours la légitime
kidal j'en parle en connaissance de
cause
enfin il ya un homme dans votre vie est
belle même marié c'est mieux que rien
alexis m'a cité l'autre jour un proverbe
chinois par action il est d'une telle
culture il me fait souvent des citations
savez je l'accompagné plusieurs faire sa
promenade du soir pour qu'on digère pas
que ce soit demain pour l'instant la
chine a utilisé un proverbe chinois ont
voulu connaître ici ou là certainement
déjà si tu allais a longtemps retardé
c'est comme ça tout de suite assure
officiellement souvenirs correctement
c'est l'amour est comme un citron vert à
la fois doux et amer s'ils changent le
goût des choses il appelle aussi la soie
ouais si jolie les parabènes pour
session savez-vous de candidat et ça va
naturellement et si c'est tous les 3e
siècle avant jésus-christ aurez vous
faites pas d'argument à lui revenir du
village arfa mais il faut absolument que
j'aille m'occuper du déjeuner qu'est ce
que vous avez prévu comme dessert au
citron vert
on retiendra de ces repas des salles pas
des enfants ma conscience je me suis
débrouillé tout seul dans fou très belle
étoile
bonjour un briquet voilà
quand on vous demande vous y croire 26
gracieux c'est un plaisir d'être
convoqué par jour aussi rigolo de voir
bon alors qu'est ce qui est encore le
chienchien sa mémère c'est moi la mère
m'a dit d'un vétérinaire
la csq jeunes adultes oui les votes
craybas en garage sa libido le travail
voilà on est tous là on est vraiment
trop comme affiner la parole et
vétérinaire
celle du papa va profiter pas d'autant
plus tôt matin je suis pas du tout mais
alors pas du tout d'humeur à plaisanter
on admire on vous attend les cieux
moment je fais parti vert ça ne s'impose
pas ou plus la gnôle il avait l'air
d'avoir déjà fait le plein et la jument
kaniba chez le blanc chaud avant rose
sauf quand c'est pas la jument c'est là
tout est dit dans sa m'étonne pas que
votre femme vous ai quitté mondiale
buvez pas vraiment un mois qu au moins
était déjà trop et comment vont les
gosses on se lie les chez sa grand-mère
pour les vacances et je prends eric à
partir du 15 accords ne seraient pas
quoi faire envoyer le nouail réunion tam
tous à petit on demande même comment il
peut être bâtie suis pas tellement sûr
qu'il ne soit justement les gens
l'aiment tout comme 1,15 à gaza
si vous freinez un peu sur la bouteille
que seriez plein des poudres la main là
oublient mais pas aussi désabusé offre
il ya les animaux et l'agneau des
heureusement parce que si je deviens
voire à faire toute la journée à des
bonnes femmes dans votre genre
j'aimerais mieux vendre soit possible
mais pour vous supporter votre mari mais
c'était un sacré sarasar vrai ça c'est
bien mon ami
la cuisine un problème n'est pas là à
quel point rien rien rien rien à la
cuisine
comment avez-vous leur petit 1.6 your
face à la 85e non mais moi de bien
penser que je vais annonce je connais
rien aux abords de leurs figures papier
sur la plage je suis tombé sur les
durand belle et chaude sur les quoi
aller durant bénichou n'a pas dû c'est
très bien monsieur madame durand bel et
je compte acheter la pomme regarder ces
gens épouvantable oui ça y est ça
recommence tu vas pas déblatérer contre
qu'il ne connaît même pas rêver face il
fallait alors mercedes blanche ça va
susciter juge un peu rapide bobby
rouleau moins ce qu'est ce qui se passe
avec les droits des niches mais j'ai
envie de prendre l'apéritif tout de
suite je me suis vraiment mais c'est pas
vrai n'ai pas pu faire autrement le
monde dieu mais quelques bars et une en
moi en prend pour un jeune qui commence
par avait voulu rendre cette invitation
à dîner un engrenage habituelles voilà
encombrer les de revel échelons jusqu'à
la fin de nos jours finit la paix y'a
plus qu'à liquider la baraque et émigré
en corrèze dans le oui nous attendons
trop dure en mêlée shaun c'est la vie
marion cela s'appelle entretenir les
rapports de bon voisinage n'ont rien à
craindre du tout 5 e par personne
je l'invité à vie en attendant tu vas me
faire le plaisir de revoir les durand
belle et chaude aimablement pas pourquoi
pour ce que je demande à signer kaka
bonjour madame je suis malade durant
bénichou
mais ça va être à la maison cossue de
cette intrusion géré madame mais votre
mari assis aimablement ici ça nous
voulions pas manqué l'occasion de faire
votre connaissance en tentant de nous
présenter dans une tenue aussi des bras
il est embêté dit tu habitais bonne
saison on va voyons georgina ce à quoi
j'ai prêté main forte à un égo qui
défriche le petit bois on aimerait que
je n'ai rien à dire j'ai pinet toute la
matinée dans mon jardin d'herbes de
potash d'air
on est vraiment crade autres ou les deux
brunes pays sans on vous fait pas trop
peur
je suis sûr que vous vous attendiez à
voir débarquer des merisiers sophistiqué
qui s'amusent à faire un peu de
jardinage d'affaires m de week-end à
vous et à vous et le javaux nous voilà
rassurés rock combien manquer mais je
vous en prie mes samia j ai voici vous
prendrai bien verte rendez vous
représentez marion toutes les modalités
pour les abeilles nationale leurs
bénévoles encore s'il reste et pour
déjeuner pas sûr que l'ancien pas chez
vous et nous nous y plaisons veut
prouver premier d'hectares avez vous un
nid ya pas mal à ce que j'appelle être
sage
nous avons près de 60 ha oui je tape sur
ma faim ou bien protéger son
environnement on a protégé jamais assez
moi j'ai pour les films de fer barbelés
avec un courant à haute tension
alors vous voilà devenu le nouveau
jardin d'à part au choc
il ya même pop tour muscadet avec les
très volontiers
c'était un peu marre du scotch vous
trouvez pas que quelqu'un veut-il de la
glace je viens chercher je vous ai des
neuf races avec les invités mon chéri
oui oui je peux très bien la d820 il
était de 6 m à 4 pour le personnel
comment vous débrouillez vous dire que
j'ai beaucoup de chance
après pas mal de déboires je suis tombé
sur une perte possible
elle travaille comme un jeu femmes
jeunes la paye rien et naturellement pas
déclarés aux assurances sociales
c'est sûrement pas une française ainsi
tout à plus haut mais méfiez-vous connu
l'offre davantage ailleurs et qu elle ne
vouloir aucun risque même en y
multipliant ses gages celle là vous ne
me l'enlèverez pas mais qui est ce c'est
demain 17 mois
évidemment l'idéal serait de se passer
complètement des agnostiques remarquer
didier et moi nous vivons très
simplement à l'américaine tous les
dimanches nous prenons nos repas à la
cuisine ça elle est équipée ultra
moderne avec tous les gadgets possibles
et imaginables il suffit d'appuyer sur
un bouton
c'est bien j'ai entendu quelqu'un
frapper les boutons comme ça mais
lancement du jeu c'est fou c'est fou ce
que ça mélange même si sa musique une un
rien suffit pour la réveiller
tu ne devrais pas boire moi je dirais un
muscadet qui fait mal mais moi la
vésicule je peux laisser ses rangs le
fait est là sur scène à diminuer aucune
de mes facultés galles au contraire et
voilà qui est encourageant et bien pas
moi c'est bien c'est super de propriété
à l'entrée du village mais exactement
vous savez que je fais construire une
piscine 25 mètres une vraie piscine mal
fini ça y aura de la place pour tout le
monde alors si le coeur vous en dit vous
avez marre mais je n'aime pas les bonnes
vagues mais nous avons si la machine à
faire des vagues
mais c'est disneyland non plus éparses
ou un savant et ma foi ce sont des
animaux si sensible près ce rapport
enfin la maison est ouverte en
permanence et les amis de nos amis sont
nos amis aux ardennes une grande fiesta
pour l'accord démontrait manière et pour
tous les samedis y aura un buffet
barbecue autour de la piscine
eh bien voilà qui va créer une certaine
animation dans notre paisible localité
oui est ce qu'il ya des gens
fréquentables dans le secteur et que
vous en donnez pas fréquentable les gens
avec qui on peut parler échanger des
idées je veux aussi mais parce que
voyez-vous chez nous c'est très relax
mais attention là horreur des branches
pourries des noms ou enfin vous voyez ce
que je veux dire un
nous sommes des anticonformistes c'est à
dire que chez nous les artistes avaient
donc toujours à bouffer maintenant vous
savez vous mettre de l'effet
terriblement impressionné par bob
bourdieu pourquoi mais vous êtes un
virtuose mondialement comme la
télévision vous passez jamais la télé
non666 m'arrive donné l'hiver dernier
j'ai donné un concerto de béla bartok
oui sur le direct en carrière caracas
labadie dont nous nos fusées volent et
discrétion est un artiste de votre
classe quand tu donnes un concert est ce
que ça prend le coup je veux dire que
des fréquences raconter mon mari et d'un
matérialisme babeau comme ça que je
n'aurais pas dû dire ce que je mérite
pas surtout c'est très mauvais pour ma
visite sûrs
no mais rassurez-vous sans rouler sur
l'or nous manquons de rien je gagne très
correctement
et puis quand on n'arrive pas à joindre
les deux bouts et ben moi je me remets à
toi ottawa à pardies
je me permets de vous signaler que ma
femme a le sens de la plaisanterie
particulièrement plus que mais surtout
quand elle est demeuré coi vigueur six
mois mois à choisir alors alors mon cher
alex et vous permet de zapper la victime
mais je vous en prie est-ce qu il ya une
bonne ambiance à la pommeraye forêt vous
amenez votre instrument et gounod julien
boutter ah non je vais craquer les
teasers manque à mon répertoire mondial
évidemment demain notre répertoire tout
cas valeur de l'être alexis week-end par
l'extra dans les dîners en ville voulait
lui faire part battu non non mais qu'est
ce que c'est que ces ploucs
mais vous avez bien deviné pas fait
manger des flots qui je vous le répète
le peuple juif le club
c'est déjà bon dieu que c'était
rafraîchir ou non merci
non merci teddy je crois qu'il est temps
de rompre déjà madame vous pouvez vous
appuyez sur ses terrasses et cali une
petite brise exclure nous trouvons porte
petite brise ou le dimanche
oui mais
robes et les chenilles des lipides l
argent une référence qui est allé un peu
fort quand vous allez je n'ai plus rien
comme c'est dit ritalin storia vous la
beauté comme dans les quelques détails
qui fait remarquer je note mes racines
sentiment que vous devez savoir leur
gueule en selle par hasard comment vous
citerai pas les proverbes chinois gelos
comprends j'ai compris la seul coup les
écarts ils me sont tombés les yeux une
passe et trouver des codes jolie et son
pouce et aux confidences et moi je me
débats les jours a confié ma vie j'en
connais ma fille toute la ville mais si
tu n as roma la noria je ne comprenais
rien et tout ça se passait devant -
selon toi pauvre conne que de tels
enjeux vous souhaitez acheter c'est
peut-être été arrêtés d'alexis mais
c'était évident mine est folle de lui un
homme marié qui passe tout le week-end
avec sa femme elle est bien bonne
vous voulez signer tout de même pas que
je décroche et arrêter lange affirme
qu'à ce qu'il faut pour faire d'autres
mais il me semblait le christ démarrage
se fait pas maintenant chacun tue pas
folle
les percer à jour au contraire nouveaux
airs de victimes que j'étais bien et que
j'ai été bon non je me suis dit c'est
pas le plus cité mais là je ne peux plus
me laisser prendre
c'est moi qui vous plaît c'est plus haut
que tout marion rien pourquoi ces
regardant si injuste non non il y aurait
coûté moi je suis votre homme pouvez
vous imaginer un seul instant du vitrail
tous très bons textes vous savez pour
moi comme ça qu'on les remercie avec moi
prendre l'extérieur même si c'est un
cauchemar à la fois coach quelques
regrets votre après midi à serrières
avec l excision et de maman je vous jure
pauvre femme doit décider d'en
débarrasser
avec un excitant m'est égal je vous lis
ne suis pas jalouse mais que vous vous
croyez obligé de jouer la comédie de
l'amitié voilà c'est pas mignon ça n'est
quand même pas que vous trouviez en
cachette à paris tous les deux et lexie
n'a pas quitté le moulin depuis quinze
jours c'est bien le conte en emploi du
temps je veux bien entendre davantage sa
grille drolet méchants très méchants
marulaz emma véhicule
voilà quand je ne crois pas qu'on le
revoit les durand bénévoles de sitôt un
bravo bravo tu t'es sûr pensé fois
d'accord ce sont des ploucs
enfin qui était vraiment nécessaire de
le renvoyer en pleine gueule nous est
passé de monter dans sa chambre
moi je fais à mon nom alors a pour une
fois tu avais raison les charmants mais
je l'observé pendant les visites et
durant bénévoles étaient parfaites
sachant se tenir si bien simple aux
dépens de l'as écrit sa place sauf des
besoins ah bon parce qu'avant j'étais
pas suffisamment aimable avec elle
maintenant j'ai le malheur de
reconnaître qu'elle est de bonne
compagnie et ça ne va pas non plus je
t'assure qu'il aimerait longtemps qu'il
fasse opérer d'un véhicule et les
citrons ils sont toujours vers la fin
est forte en chinois mais quelle
proverbe chinois quand on lit les
proverbes chinois dans la serre comme
c'est romantique et tu t'en souviens
même pas non je me souviens pas excuser
la sécu rebelles ce sera très bien à l
abri en soirée puis en train d'imaginer
des choses idiotes va drainer en tout
cas des choses qui n'existent pas ton
ferme
oui en effet j'ai cité ce proverbe
chinois l'autre jour un papa tient à son
propos oui nous étions en train qu'en
victo à nontron pas vous pas mes droits
je lui disais que bien que tu sois la
pire des emmerdeuses de était la seule
qui font des progrès a dit ça tu vas pas
me reprocher donc les saignements
délicate et dans quel but nahyane et si
tu peux bien me l'avouer quoi allez
allez tu as couché avec pauline d'humour
je tape les a vus ça ne serait bien
porte des lilas voyons à l'excès iqu
tiens je te jure sur la tête de maman et
ça va être une hécatombe dans li na 6
jours soit a dit sa mère qui a rien
entre vous deux all in pour capturer
fusé bien eu de mandat il n'a pas fait
sa marque guitar thème absolument profit
jeunesse en mange jamais croisé son
regard est le poteau pas te souhaiter à
la dérobée elle mais qu'est ce que tu
inventes encore bien assez canal pour
télétravail en douce et belle en mairie
avec hinault
elle tombe je fais cette allusion à
pauline comme ça très légèrement pour la
taquiner un peu voir ses réactions il
faut faire attention à tout ce qu'on dit
maintenant est une avant mon nom je
viens je suis sûr qu'il est en tout c
est en train de sangloter sur son lit ou
d'en face à rennes je reste un peu
hystérique il faut que tu montres la
console à console et puis quoi encore
c'est la moindre des choses si tu ne
comprends pas la la la rue m eur des
histoires non avec ton manque de tact
habituel but c'est encore ce que tu es
capable de me sentir non je préfère y
aller moi mais tu m'apprends mais
d'aller faire des excuses et reverra et
le rôti dans tout ça elle s'en fout 3gs
ou vice versa puis de les coller une
bonne d'eau et d'un mois sera tranquille
de ce côté là là ça va vous le prenez
vous le prenez pas puisque vous ma vie
tu si aimable malherbe blanc santé
magazine
vous êtes à combien je vous en prie -
caroline s'est ouvert les veines
on l a remis ça dans lesquels rasé sa
coupe est fière de toi que tu n as pas
forcément si tu n'avais pas vous amener
du cinéma tout ça elle cherche à se
rendre intéressant en attendant faut
faire quelque chose
sachez-le et d'autres à l'heure du
déjeuner c'est vraiment trop mal est
fait moi je crève de faim
alors casse la police il est blanc bon à
la jarrie
on ne peut même pas boire tranquillement
son frère allait dépêcher vous a peur
que son sort comme ça
attention
[Musique]
alors grâce n'a rien fait ni capture
dieu merci la terre n'était pas tout je
suis en question tu passais la chic
c'est la championne de suicide ratée
bayonne alexis vraiment trop méchant
situant bien même ça c'est la meilleure
parce que tu te donnes de décor chez une
poignée avec les limes à ongles
mais décidément sera toujours un bigot
si genève en suisse annonce un monstre
organes sac avec un tellement dire à
chacun ses vérités à 30 ans qu'ils se le
tiennent pour une fois se tiendront tous
mais coûteux les psychotropes
impressionnable oui bon bon j'ai tant de
plaisir des paulino sa vie sexuelle
mais tout ça n'est pas grave il faut
enchaîner mais ma parole je serais tu
complètement inconscients qui ont poussé
m fillon désespoir comédie 95 suicide
dans ce cas d'offre était ratée oui mais
là quand même essayer mari en cause de
thouars d'inconduite et un qualifié à la
matinée c'est pourtant ce que je tente
enfin de quel droit juges-tu de ce que
par le réseau pendant longtemps
pendant longtemps j'ai cru que des
malveillances cacher une sorte de pudeur
le jeune deux peuples et non j'ai pas
fini et je suis même persuadé que tes
paroles sont le reflet fidèle de ta
pensée alors s'il allait faire fi d oser
prétendre que le poste de coach dit
d'abord je pense pas ça ça tout seul
c'est un véritable nature qui s'explique
parce que tu es plus gai je veux
tellement dormi une bonne vache rit ça
réveille et puis ça plus rapide à trois
semaines c'était des mots quand même un
danger croissant à gré avec si tu me
connais et toi j'ai eu la dent dure
j'ai le coeur chaud je commence à en
douter
alexis tu m'aimes plus
bon j'avais fait une piqûre 40
même quand des ronds
ça ne suffit pas au nude en or et un
tranquillisant un peu plus tard voici
l'ordonance meilleur jeu jusqu'à la
formation des jeunes ont d'abord je
préparais un plateau ça nous arrange pas
mais si t'es pas de toute façon je
préfère rester seul on n'a plus besoin
de moi il faut que je passe à la grande
touche
ils ont une génisse qui a le hoquet
depuis deux jours ça c'est du sérieux
oui c'était pas grave
n'est ce pas notre ami fan a juré vous
elle est un peu exalté on dirait au fait
ne la dérangeait pas pour le moment il
se repose t elle n'a pas marqué vous qui
vous connaissez assez bien est ce que
vous trouvez que je suis une sorte
méchante vous le dirais pas cela n'est
ce pas vous êtes la reine des gars à
l'amendé fixée
vous ne vous en doutiez pas les règles
de la misogynie que vous tenez toutes
les femmes pour responsable de votre
fortune il faut faire de monde car c'est
vite dit pourquoi une garce et en plus
de tout l'a fait vous êtes une gare je
pense que vous êtes une garce dans le
patron tout le monde est d'accord là
dessus on a brûlé avec une garce la
reine des gars à ce poids là il n'y a
personne pour soutenir le contraire
avec tant de soin ce que vous dites
comment l'expliquez vous il y à de
mauvaises bête mais pourquoi ça c'est
pas pareil chez les gens et s'ils
maintenaient jamais une chienne labrador
vraiment chanceuse elle dormait au pied
de mon lit goûter mon regard des heures
entières et quand je m'absente et
refuser tout moyen d'appeler affectueux
qu'un labrador elle seulement celles
elle mordait tout le monde ne pouvait
pas s'empêcher c'était plus fort alors
qu'avez vous fait j'ai été obligé de la
dore des tout le temps chez les miens
d'écriteaux à ma porte
attention je tiens mes shows va-t-elle
faire la même chose ici attention femmes
méchant et votre mari vous promènerez en
laisse pas ça drôle du tout enfin vous
vous n'avez jamais mordu en fait blessé
moi je suis blindé alors mais vous ne
vous êtes pas privé nestlé je ne me
rendais pas corriger ce que j'ai parié
abonnement savez c'est effrayant même
quand j'ai envie de dire une chose
aimable il suffit que je n'exprime pour
ça sorte on va chez nous ça veut dire
que ça nous vient naturellement on
n'avait pas besoin de nous forcer quoi
l'attribuez vous je ne sais pas vous
vous libérer de votre agressivité
naturelle au vous défendez votre
territoire
c'est ça je défends mon territoire comme
la maison bleue j'aime la comparaison
sans préférence que les chacals nous
sommes des mésanges bleues à caissier la
méchanceté chez vous cela remonte
peut-être treuil
comment ça va il arrive que je soignerai
dit année c'est le tiens de ma grand
mère maternelle c'était une vraie
terreur mais on bat deux fois sans
sauter une génération moment n'est pas
tellement comment être non plus si je
comprends bien vous avez lu lourds
antécédents petite fille comment étiez
au physique adorable tous deux bouclé au
moral un vrai garçon manqué et casser la
gueule à mes frères
essai de crétins l'homme avait donné sur
nos lequel pots-de-vin pourquoi vous
promettiez déjà je défends des je me
défends toujours mes contre quoi contre
qui peut-être que j'ai peur vous pas
peur de ne pas être assez épais mais
vous démoraliser par à labruguière
tout le monde vous aime bien aller même
si vous êtes un renne des gars est ce
que vous croyez qu'un jeune âge on peut
changer personne ne change jamais sinon
pire à vous d'être courageux moi je le
trouve très bien comme ça en tout cas me
mais vous n'êtes pas mon mari dieu m'en
garde
entre parenthèses votre mari il a l'air
de ravoir album fait remarquer il peut
plus blairer
moi je lève mon mari c'est toute ma vie
oui bon j'ai été méchante mais pour
regarder je suis prête à tout être douze
patientes vannes
mais pour ça il faudrait que je sache
comment m'y prendre
aidez-moi casse la revue des bois allez
je vous fais la troisième
quand j'ai besoin je me sens
complètement à plat je pouvais voir plus
que diable vous savez si bien secouer
les autres et vous met dans cet état
d'abattement moi qui prends mes chats on
dit bien que tout ce qui touche au foie
une influence sur le caractère vous
permettez que je vous parle mais n'en
profitez pas aussi abattu que je sois
vincent régnier bien mama sur la figure
réserve rien pour moi là je dis souvent
c'est du pareil au même
en effet la septième part est très
sensible vous avez déjà consulté un
spécialiste attendu et avec ma face à
ses rivales toujours qu'est ce que vous
attendez pas tout à fait supportable
j'en crois votre mari ça ne l'est plus
en compte garder votre psychologie pour
les vaches
vous allez mais jamais on dirait cette
chaîne y croyais que tu dors tard c'est
vous qui me retenait avec mon histoire
la capitale
justement pour lui demander vous voir et
vous donnez pas cette peine mariage
décès en vous faire tout ça je m'en vais
pas me faire ça mais semble difficile de
rester ça l'ex idole padova jamais le
cancer ne pourra pas faire des
complications pour un petit incident
déjà oublié partout peut-être savoir
tout le soin apporté par mes propres
paroles temps vertige je pense à venise
que rien de marais le scénario je sais
on peux pas m'en vouloir je ne vous en
avait parlé souvent relié pas pauline
fourès copier il serait ce que vis à vis
d'alexis mazen est extrême je ne serai
plus le regarder en face car enfin que
doit-il pensait rien le penseur vient en
sorte qu'elle est furieux contre moi il
m'a dit des choses terribles
il n'aurait pas dû non l'escwa parce
qu'enfin vous n'êtes pas morte il s'en
est fallu de peu dans ma maison était
plein on s'était mis à nu en occuper de
vous et vous avez bénéficié sur le champ
d'une assistance médicale vous avez
terrines et un excellent vétérinaire
bref toutes les chances de votre côté
à croire que vous avez choisi votre
moment il me semble marion que c'est
vous qui l'aviez choisis ont bien sûr
bien sûr j'en suis plus qu'apple aurait
tout s'est passé pour le mieux
tout en se passant quand même très mal
mon pour revenir maintenant si vous
tenez tant soit peu à notre amitié
je crois qu'il est important que nous
dit scipion dès maintenant toute
équivoque à l équivoque cette accusation
si injuste que vous avez porté contre
moi il devait bien y avoir quelques
arrières pensées absolument temps mes
propos étaient dénuées de tout fondement
inspiré par ma seule malveillance une
montée le ville quant au fond je préfère
cela non à la réflexion voulait alexis
c'est cocasse impensable mais c'est bien
pourquoi je m'étonnais vous ils
dépensent avez vous l'impression qu'il
vous ait jamais prêté attention je
dirais même regarder mais s'est toujours
montrée d'une parfaite courtoisie à
l'échalote font la différence il a les
meilleures manières du monde le temps
qu'il a mis à se rappeler votre nom
chaque fois que vous parlez vous
demandez qui vraiment s'en vouloir vous
offenser ma petite pauline quand une
femme lui tape dans l'oeil c'est autre
chose
oui j'imagine comment bien le charmant
tu n'es plus attendre on est comme vous
le savez alexis se spécialisent de plus
en plus dans le détournement de mineure
et bien voilà qui aurait dû vous éviter
toute inquiétude à mon sujet alors cet
homme marié qui est ordonnée moi je me
suis juré d'être discrète avait raison
la boucle jamais assez seulement leur
ait pu en faire autant
je travaille mais je suis tout
déboussolé il ne peut se passer de 10 à
et puis un jour une grande tempête
secoue 16ème faire plus maintenant je
crois que vous tenez bien le sens les
choses
pas toujours bien avant de partir je
pourrais peut-être essayer de parler à
l'effort ou cias adp ne m'en voulez pas
trop il voit revenir des heures sans
talons autre habitante ennui poli
non mieux vaut le laisser venir à moi
cela aura l'air moins une équipe en leur
faisant faire un tour à léon une
question en parler nous vite
il arrive parce que vous aussi vous me
trouvez méchante au fond vous êtes la
bonté même au fond une preuve trois
trésors fou en surface que ça laisse à
désirer rêve
déjà tout petit de ses patins
raisonnable ça comment vous sentez-vous
beaucoup mieux justement j'étais en
train de vous écrire un petit mot un
petit noah - oui vous remercier de tout
avant de prendre congé
vous avez décidé de rentrer à paris oui
cela me semble préférable mais je
comprends je suis désolé mais je
comprends la première marion des proches
tous ses amis les impôts les obama sur
marion s'il vous plaît je l'adorent
voilà mon mari et mon vocabulaire eh
bien disons que je laime simplement oui
eh bien moi je lui en veux terriblement
où la maman mais les liens entre vous d
ici fin ou détrompez-vous de plus en
plus marion de fatigue m'empêche de
travail empereur seulement l'existence
est injuste et c'est vous qui la
défendent et c'est un comble quand pas
toujours appliqué une heure à peine vous
attendiez vous aurez c'est fou on sait
qu on avait passé
oui oui je veux bien par colliers faits
sont sans réelle volonté de vous tuer
même si vous avez commis ce geste père
aimant théâtrale attend que ça enfin
c'est quand elle pose de marion alexis
pas à cause des mesures à cause des vous
ce que vous allez là si folle folle
vous vous voulez que je vous rappelle
que cela je démens saisir très vite vous
ne voulez pas boire quelque chose non
d'ailleurs je vois partie alors non non
reposez-vous quand même si j'y vais
courage vous parlez comme je le fais
alexis c'est que je sais que je vais
partir dans quelques instants que vous
ne me reverrez plus jamais oui vous vous
êtes vega georgenthum ce moment et
j'espère oui oui après je me sentirais
bien oui mais vous devez bon schéma rien
oublier un instant écoutez moi puisque
j'y tenais absolument votre femme
n'avait pas complètement tort
mais cette redoutable prescience qui est
la sienne elle allait au fond de moi une
vérité que je me refuse à admettre mais
qu'est ce que vous cherchez mon petit
vous dit ne pas jouer le jeu vous fait
un grand plus de culpabilité ou mais
coûterait que vous le vouliez ou pas et
j'en viens vous jette des sites est bon
mais cette fois ci je vous ai compris
alexis je suis amoureux et c'est à vous
j'ai toujours dit je suis très flatté
mais je ne prenais pas sûr c'est ton
persifleur pas l'habitude avec les
admiratrices d'arrossa scène marion que
vous en raconter ça quel est le virtuose
qui échappe au fanatisme fulmine il
paraît que j'ai un vibrato dévastateur
suffisante et bien sûr vous tiré de
votre violoncelle des résonances qui
déchireront leur nomination tricheuse je
ne tiens pas cinquième bague à votre
front si noble alors des milliers à
renier complètement la première fois que
je vous ai vu il m'est impossible de
m'intéresser à nos propres et vous
montez la tête en visant comme vous que
vous avez ça
marion qui dort sur marion marion parle
à tort et à travers vous savez bien des
passages où les cartonnettes il n'est
pas envisageable qu'il n'y ait jamais
quoi que ce soit un prêt n'est pas parce
que sam est envisagée mais il m'arrive
toujours mon ami il vous êtes son avis
mais j'en vois rien sur le plan conjugal
mario est une femme admirable avec si
l'équilibré à couper quelque chose
difficile à maintenir cela ne va pas
sans heurts sans mal entendu à vous
l'avez remarqué mais enfin et là elle
est la vigilance solide et fidèle
je n'en ai jamais douté produit jamais
quel et essayez de vous tromper avec un
de vos confrères ne prête pas à
conséquence
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça suffit ça
veut dire se mettre au lit avec un
dossier que ça ne colle pas parce que
j'ai mise au lit avec un de mes
confrères sur la fois cause et si vous
ne saviez pas bah non je ne savais pas
maintenant nous perdons jusqu'ici
pardonnable avoir ainsi que l'a fait
c'est d'abord qui est plus connu mais
maintenant vous tirez viennois fardeau
même s'il y en a nous assurer qu'ils
n'ont pas compté les environs je suis
sûr qu'il sait crise qui empire ottoman
est restée pas d'ailleurs marion n'a
fait allusion à cette aventure que pour
mieux démontrer son incurable et
finalité c'est un garçon christian
guérinet bien cela n'a pas suffi
voyez-vous heureuse à mai d'accord c'est
ce qu'attend par l'insee donnez moi
votre train de dire que vous ne
répèterai jamais à marans qui m'a
échappé si malencontreusement ont
rassuré vous laisse à date ça suffit
comme ça va interpréter cela comme je lé
compris comme une preuve d'amour de sa
part singulier détour voilà je vais
quitter cette maison confie je pars un
peu meurtri mais je me concerne le
disons que mon séjour ici n'aura pas été
tout à fait inutile s'il a contribué
tant soit peu à resserrer les liens qui
les unissent mario
quelle drôle de film that all in je ne
doutais pas mais vous était aussi en
vidéo c'est complexe
au moins ça donc je voulais que trop
tard plus grandes décisions mondiales et
que je voulais vous voyez témoins des
engagements que je vais prendre tout ça
et bien sûr les si j'étais plus
magnifique voyez le mal partout
j'interprète et bassement le meilleur
attention les autres je juge à ras du
sol et parmi eux notons autocritique il
est grand temps que vous connaissez mes
torts mieux que je dirais pas je me
croyais tellement des patentes et bien
je ne l'était pas à le voir ce que les
défauts les autres os aveugle sur les
siens dans la salle bonnes femmes sont
toujours aussi excessifs vous avez vous
taisez vous et à prier écouté pas mal de
grain de sel
bon tout cela nous mais n'a pas envie
d'y revenir si j'ai décidé de faire un
complet retour sur moi même devenir
quelqu'un d'autre en avant d'être panne
pour marion c'est vite dit la
bienveillance et un pli apprendre et
pour commencer
ça me faire opéré de la vésicule voilà
ah ben voilà une bonne résolution même
si cela ne doit pas changer ton coeur à
faire pour moi ce sera du d'avoir mal de
disques elle m'a dit mais j'ai bon
espoir il paraît que c'est fou ce que
cette petite poche peut contenir de
méchanceté ya un enjeu sera jamais
débarrassé d'elle et délivrer de mon
excellent bill tueur en face de toi une
marion tout en sucre bavante mansuétude
une sainte française d'homer des
dommages et intérêts je vous obligerait
à me payer des dommages et intérêts que
c'est monsieur collines et vous restez
pas le reset appareil c'est tout con
gestionnaire le sera moins votre un
travail mal a encore fait des siennes
les rôles étaient avec moi là il a dû
échapper à votre vigilance puisque j'ai
trouvé faisant la corrida dans mon pool
a dû se prosterner et pas boucler ma
meilleure pondeuses y est passé je vous
présente toutes mes condoléances à
garder les c1 ne remplacera pas mais eux
dû jouer écouter monsieur colina j'ai
une petite grille c'est du très
prolifique
je vous l'offre le grand coeur pour vous
dédommager mais elle pourrait le pont
c'est un p
un héron je vous promets qu'il ne
recommencera plus ça je me vais vite vos
premières ce poids monsieur collines et
pourquoi je veux absolument faire la
peau vers les caisses que ça qu'est ce
que ça cache toutes ces belles paroles
pourquoi se quereller au fond vous aide
un très brave homme avait comment
viennent vos tomates cette année allez
l'on tousse on vient rabougri a propos
je vous félicite pour vos dahlias je les
ai aperçus par dessus la haie ils sont
superbes les mots surtout comment vont
les varices le madame pauline allégée
des 10 euros ce matin
offrez-lui de ma part avec mes
compliments sera bientôt monsieur
collins ya un problème n'hésitez pas à
me retrouver surtout entre nous les
choses s'arrangeront toujours le monde
devrait toutefois être agréable
on a la bougeotte savez-vous monsieur
collinaires que je vous trouve très
sympathique
sans blague merci je m'en serais jamais
douté il semble pas pour nous enfants
partir de maintenant ils sont les
meilleurs voisins de mon rythme
au québec
on n'est pas plus difficile ce sens
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors comment va-t-elle premier monsieur
câliner mais elle revient bientôt
laisser s'amorcer drucker est elle alla
chercher abri de cette somme à coeur pur
brad smith a été le roi cette absence ce
jour de crédits qu'ils semaine les
bombes à l'essence dans le midi c'est un
minimum pour une opération comme celle
là à trois semaines seulement
relationnel et semblait plus long mais
la brière sera très touchée quand elle
apprendrait que cette ville chaque jour
prendre leucémie paroisse où j'avais
jamais rien d'autre à faire un choix
et si calme j'ai vu qu'elle est partie
médiane échange d'efforts le christ le
mot n'a plus à mairi plus rien pour ces
dames vallini qui va apprécier sa
sérénité des débats vous savez elle me
demande qu'il tente alors pas que s'il
ya de nouveaux deux côtés de la reine
alors qu'est ce que vous lui je lui
réponde bien la signaler avant avant je
lui faisais mon petit rapport alors on
avait l'esprit occupé un mois j'étais à
l'avant poste dans le jardin toujours
sur le qui vive et ma femme surveillez
l'ennemi derrière son rideau à lorsqu'il
est en haleine on vivait quoi c'est
d'abord le plus dérangé au moins vous
pouvez cultiver en fait votre potager
évidemment seulement c'est toujours la
même chose vous savez on la voit les
légumes ça manque un peu de suspense
lorsqu'on comprend que vous regrettez
vous escarmouches quotidienne avec
madame bruyères à n'ont pas dit non mais
je m'étais habitué à nos engueulades et
madame pauline est aussi alors forcément
major on n'a plus rien à se dire
rassurez-vous labruquère nous ranger un
peu d'animation 1
pourvu qu'ils allaient repris du poil de
la bête mais vous savez un quand je les
ai vus si calme si douce avec moi j'ai
tout de suite compris que quelque chose
ne marchait pas elle faisait pitié
ga les guérés maintenant vous allez la
retrouver plein de vitalité semblable à
elle-même l'auditori faut que j'aille
annoncé ça madame colinet elle en
devenait complètement neurasthénique
[Applaudissements]
envion mario la jouer comme je me sens
légère
si les normes
comment s'est passé ce séjour à man à
merveille le temps était radieux et tout
le personnel de l'hôtel au petit soin
pour moi il me fallait bien cela pour me
consoler la marque quitter la clinique
sagna déchirement de me séparer de mes
infirmières de mon chirurgien
quant à mon rallye matters c'était mon
grand fleuve bref je les adorais tous
pour commander vous dirai oui je le suis
moi aussi adam s'est métamorphosé en
quittant la clinique j'avais la larme à
l'oeil
tous ces braves gens souvent modestes
qui s'oublie eux mêmes qui se dévouent
pour leurs semblables c'est grand c'est
beau
est ce que ça ne vous fait pas aimer
l'humanité vous me pardonnerez de n'être
pas venu vous rendre visite régionale
m'accaparer et ainsi me tenir au courant
de votre santé aujourd hui je me voyais
pas l'élever tout excuser l'aurions fait
de la queue pour entrer dans ma chambre
ça on peut dire que j'ai été gâtée
on ne savait plus où mettre les fleurs
tous les bases de la clinique étaient
réquisitionnés pour moi les roses
s'entassent dans le bidet
il fallait voir ça une vraie chambre de
stains lâchait maman d'alexis est venu
tous les jours malgré sa sciatique
jusqu'à jim herman qui s'est dérangé le
fidèle du bernabeu le feeder zimmermann
du poney dans la banque est vraiment une
crapule de toute façon justice turque il
nous aime beaucoup
à ce propos je l'invité avec sa petite
amie pour le prochain week-end c'est pas
un peu beaucoup ça n'attend jamais au
juste milieu avec moi mon chéri je
m'attends sur toi tout un tas gars et
paul sagna ses week-ends suivants qui
viendront et gaëtan et sonia l'horloge
et volante on n'est absolument pas je
leur ai téléphoné balayant les vieilles
rancunes le moulin ne va pas désempli on
n'a jamais de te voir fallait au moins
chéri quand on enlève le véhicule d'être
aussi bas une telle différence quand je
te reconnais plus tu exagères qu'en
pensez vous pauline ménage avec une main
celle que j'ai maintenant de vous c'est
particulièrement gentil ce que voulait
dire là mais que la maison un joli mot
dit de l'eau les bienvenus ravissante
vous cavité d'un coeur pour un art aussi
bien préparer mon retour ne pourra les
cités perdues alors je suis venue de
temps en temps aussi de mettre un peu de
mes chaussures qu'il ne sait pas servir
comme apache ah je te recommande le
cocktail de jus de suite polyvalents
vers les larcins je vous en ferai marion
vient d'ailleurs un pichet au frigidaire
qui vous attend lors elle a toutes les
attentions alors on est venus souvent
mon pauvre sa licence souvent j'ai
réussi à m'échapper ces trois derniers
week-ends et aujourd'hui je voulais pas
manquer votre rythme avec ses dessins
très sage presque trop c'est vrai ça
j'ai beaucoup travaillé aussi de leurs
achats sans dire on s'est juste
batailler pour lui faire prendre l'air
de tenir son petit tour jusqu en dire
autant par tout de même le fut pas plus
que de la fumée était content mais c'est
un miracle qu'elle force de caractère
comment osez-vous prix pauline pour le
décider je ne sais pas si cela vous
ferait plaisir mais on n'est pas encore
entendu aboyer il ne voit plus de ce
qu'il fallait dresser gérant collins
était l'ange gardien de celle où je vais
monter mes affaires dans la chambre mais
mais n'est ce pas monsieur collinet qui
émerge aussi haricots et j'aperçois
madame collinet qui guette derrière ses
rideaux roses oui allez braves gens ont
reculé de le retrouver tout son petit
monde
j'ignorais mon bonheur et bien
maintenant je veux le savourer au
maximum
voilà et c'est comme ça depuis
l'aéroport les écluses dans la
bienveillance
mais il faut croire qu'elle en avait
beaucoup moins réserve je suis un peu
déconcerté inattendu était encore sous
le coup du choc opératoire est peut-être
en tout cas pour moi qui pratiquent
marion depuis bientôt 25 ans ce
déploiement de suavité non-stop ne
laisse pas de surprendre
mais la forme est là découragés par mois
je disais bien que je ne sois pas tout à
fait convaincu je ne demande qu'à y
croire oui pourvu que ça dure c'est sûr
qu'elle ne se doute de rien or ni pour
nous de regarder les antennes ça une
fois aucun prix qu'elle après les faits
ce qui s'est passé entre nous c'est un
peu ça faut je voulais partir elle m'a
obligé à rester jamais revenu au moulin
en son absence si elle n'avait de temps
assisté n'irai pas jusque là je savais
qu'il y avait un danger on a trouvé seul
avec vous mais je me croyais plus fort
ne pensez pas que vous viendriez si
facilement à bout de la résistance
enfin si je me souviens bien c'est vous
qui le soir même du départ de marion il
entrait dans la chambre nue sous votre
baignoire pour me réaffirmé qu'il était
question de rien entre nous j'étais
sincère oui mais oui c'est là vous
autorisez sans doute abusé de la
situation
je vous ai trouvé trouvé plutôt
coopératif ne soyez pas errani sait bien
qu'une femme a toujours tort franchement
y'a pas de quoi épiloguer
vous êtes une femme plus que désirable
une sensualité camou frais mais non
moins réel et moi hélas je ne suis pas à
l'abri de saint jean 2 tentation
alors nous avons eu envie de la même
chose en même temps c'était très sympa
ces moments de plaisir mise à m'envoyer
nous n'irons pas trop il ne peut donc
être que sans lendemain mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on ajoute je vais m'y mets ma
petite femme intelligente et j'ai très
bien que mes petits écarts de conduite
n'entame en rien les griffes d'un autre
coup j'avais cru être pour vous un peu
plus qu'un écart de conduite
on voit que je vous ai connu alexis
gautier comme domestique et par une
femme dominatrice avec moi des fois il
me semblait que vous avez retrouvé un
peu de votre indépendance de votre
dignité d'homme vous savez ma dignité
vous proposez vous travaillez votre
violoncelle ces derniers jours j'ai
l'impression que vous étiez
particulièrement inspiré quelques
oeuvres sur papier
vous savez même à mon âge en fait des
progrès tous les jours récit je vous
comprends bien ce que je vous ai apporté
c'est encore à elle est peut-être
n'at-elle pas tous favorisant trop ce
qu'elle soit bien sûr d'elle pour ne pas
craindre d'être pris à son propre jeu et
quand c'est pour mon bien encore
l'horizon
c'est sublime ya elle est revenue il
faut tourner la page quand il met vite
compliqué de chaud cela inutilement
je ne suis pas de ces femmes tout ça
comme un des situations boiteuse je vous
offre mon amitié bien un plongeon de
l'amitié si ça vous arrange les avis de
marion
si ni mais ça n'est pas le moindre de
vos chars mérité à quelqu'un va beaucoup
mieux pas adoptée permettrait d'en
décider qu'il advienne je garderai
aventure alors appris que ça serait
dommage d'en rester là
en tout cas que marion l'on sache jamais
rien on rit alors là vous pouvez compter
sur moi nous voyons tout à l'heure aux
frais des l'cie du temps du jeu
m'émerveiller jeune homme fils trompé sa
femme avec autant d'aisance faut pas s'y
fier de moi une maligne faveur je vais
réunir le mont fuji tv line enfin
presque
soyez très très gentil avec la rue j'ai
cueilli des framboises je vais faire une
tarte
marion adore la perte prend d'oise
[Applaudissements]
les moi aussi j'adore la tarte aux
framboises
c'est bien drake moi aussi c'est que
c'est mon jardin qui va le plus manqué
non je me dois après toi bien sûr mon
chéri je n'ai quand même pas d'être de
retour à temps pour profiter encore de
mes dernières raw et bien tu vois tant
attendu comme un soldat venu réparer la
brèche à le petit mais je les relance
est 36 fois rien à faire il a fait
tellement chaud mais pas tant que ça
quand il s'agit d'envoyer sa facture je
compte sur toi pour l'anglais à dire
gentiment les choses l'obtient souvent
de bien meilleurs résultats
c'est un nouvelle tactique et oui mieux
vaut tard que jamais et puis je ne
saurais plus quoi engager quelqu'un au
droit du mans et a sur le coeur n'y est
plus il ya deux nouveaux clans le pays
si possible aussi que figure toi que la
bande de voyous encore semer la terreur
oui mais ils ont tous caché au
supermarché et violé la grosse jour cela
cépages radidi non oui d'autant plus
qu'ils vont remettre ça ou sous prétexte
qu'ils sont mineurs ont les arrêtant
leur tirer les oreilles après on le
relâche aussitôt indiqué la prison la
maison le redressement arrangera les
choses sous les verrous nous serions 30
qui n'a que trop abusé de ce genre de
répression la criminalité ne cesse
d'augmenter dans le remède est ailleurs
dans une plus grande compréhension
c'est la société qui a fait ce qu'ils
sont ces gamins nous sommes tous
responsables et les mines de st dieu
merci il n'y en a pas en france et toi
même qui me l'a signalé
en tout cas les durs en bd should le
réseau de points de même façon dont non
ils ont fait installer tout un système
d'alarmé est acheté deux dobermans prêts
à vous sauter à la gorge son service de
punch à lui aussi attaché à la biens
matériels les pauvres mais pourquoi me
parler dessus des duran bénévoles qui
les a revus de loin oui oui ce après
l'accueil que tu leur as a service' pas
pourquoi mais ils sont plutôt penser
quand ils me rancourt a c'est vrai j'ai
et épouvantable mais ce jour là ma
visite une menace et si fort faut
absolument que je rattrape ça mais à
quel titre elle aux français ces gens là
ils veulent et vernoux animés d
attention aux non non ça je suis
déterminé à leur faire à grands frais en
or mariani ça va durer longtemps droit
dans mon chéri cette comédie quelle
comédie de l'argent sur la gentillesse
de l'altruisme ce n'est pas une comédie
mon chéri je suis vraiment devenu comme
ça du jour au lendemain comme par magie
parce qu'on te paierai de vie sans doute
quel autre explication va-t-il utopie
mais absolument pas sans doute mon
évolution avec un tel pas uniquement à
l'ablation de ce petit organe mais j'ai
beaucoup réfléchi haïti beaucoup et puis
surtout bon alexis j'ai eu si peur de
tout perdre mais je n'ai jamais mental
cela il suffit à changer complètement
interne à tunis et bien que quand j'ai
décidé quelque chose je finis toujours
par y arriver alors que voilà devenu bon
et je ne suis pas boire mon chéri je ne
suis plus méchante un point c'est tout
pour être bonne j'ai encore un long
chemin
le revirement est spectaculaire je ne
voyais que les défauts les autres je ne
vois plus que leur qualité
testo l'optique je t'ai dit c'était un
petit apprend mon vent de changement
d'homme comme se croire que si quand je
suis tentée de critiquer ça m'arrive
encore du c'est quand je sens que j'ai
blessé à l'aine mesquinerie et bien je
respire profondément et je me répète de
plus haut à riom prend le plus haut des
tâches toi marion lâche là j'ouvre les
mains et rejoint ses hautes sphères où
tout est amour tu redescends quand même
de temps en temps des mots gentils
animateurs a prêté un ouvrage très
remarquable sur la philosophie est de
gauche ça m'a beaucoup aidé si tu savais
comme si reposant d'aimer son prochain
avant j'étais tendu sur la défensive
ruminant toujours une vacherie voit matt
oleksy comme je suis apaisé complètement
quelconque et dont ils avaient tous
l'infortuné fiant il ne te reste plus
qu'à mettre à exécution toutes tes
bonnes résolutions j'en ai bien
attention et pour commencer de v2
j'appelle carole je sais que
tactiquement qui a menti aux ça c'est
inutile tant que refusant de revoir ce
garçon ce n'est pas pour rien qu'elle
est ta fille elle est aussi buté que toi
alors qu'un jour ma chérie c'est moi
brad a remercié pour le petit mot qui
maillent à la clinique oui tout s'est
très bien passé
tu sais bien je suis increvable fait
finir de me retaper au moulin à huy non
non ne bougeront pas pendant tout le
mois alors à ce propos ton père et moi
nous serions très heureux si tu venais
passer quelques jours avec nous et bien
entendu tu amènerait ton étudiant en
sociologie
ça va toujours vous 2 à laval où nous
sommes apportées des mois au départ oui
il m'arrive de me braquer pour rare
qu'un mal baisées mal baisées que ça
veut dire ça nous sommes tout mal
baisées n'est ce pas
à
c'est attendu chéri quand un coup de fil
balance en votre visite à tous les deux
embrasse bien fort et on barbu aussi
puisque la ville est restée sans voix
il ya de quoi tu vois ce n'est pas
raisonnable et marion plus brille et
rallongé je souhaitais pas richesse donc
avec un coussin à coeur au lait reste
allez vous pour lire votre courrier ces
lettres sont arrivées ce matin
merci beaucoup oui vous que j'en ai
cherchés vos lunettes sombres aux élus
qu'il alexis alexis va me traiter les
scarlets merci beaucoup
ça c'est la facture des pépiniéristes
oh le joli tatiana rojo tu as vu la
belle facture mais très jeune âge une
carte postale de la fiole au hockey les
drôles et attentionné cette petite si
j'en juge d'après la gare c'est
ravissant palavas les flots alors as tu
es vraiment déterminés à tout trouvés
sans vie datant janata n'êtes pas cette
écriture nom alors je le fais tu connais
pas madame changer d'usagé tedx allez
rire alors pourquoi tu les rochers mais
c'est vraiment quand vous êtes tout pas
là que je sais que ça ne va pas que la
vie est donc ces saletés là le site ou
jamais signé dans un style et rennes et
lille où et comment on peut perdre
l'amour si bien que contiendrait des
calomnies squeak à li kath et lunettes
qui n'est pas révolté non c'est tout à
fait tout à fait je ne voudrais pas
paraître a dit la boîte aux lettres
modernes et moi aussi
ben voyons c'est ignoble et d'être la
maîtresse alex et moi je suis écoeuré en
asie dans aucun pays qui donne le droit
cherche trois blessés marion est ainsi
pourquoi moi tu n'as pas mis 63
maintenant à pauline imagination voilà
tout un vieux ménage une jeune femme
nouvelle venue nombreuse pour qu'on en
tire des conclusions d'ailleurs je
n'avais je pas que des mois mais non pas
de les envoyer lettre anonyme 7h et des
gorges vous enfin dit lutter avec mes
enfants demeurent catastrophe et il ya
vraiment pas de quoi parce que c'est
faux si heureuse mariant que vous le
preniez si bien mais c'est la seule
façon de preah vihear tout cas quelqu'un
cherché à semer la zizanie en tongs
j'aimerais bien connaître ce [ __ ]
kevin écriture de femme et l'a fait
tomber mes enfants si cet agrès les
choses seraient différentes mais qui
mieux que nous et placé pour savoir que
ce n'est pas vrai la seule attitude
appréhender leurs rires
allez faites comme moi rigoler comme ça
valérie alex terry ne lâchez pas en fait
il me royal qu'il n'y en a pas mal ça
l'auteur de la lettre à l'année
la spa etc si oui très bon et joyeux
faut que je termine ma transposition de
l'accord table de shu uemura continue à
penser à sa crête rich iott non mais
c'est fini c'est oublié je ne peux voir
ce pays soucieux à ton franc oui bon on
se promet même ne plus jamais faire
allusion plus promis ma gentille petite
pauline va me tenir compagnie au nouveau
pôle innovation vos amours
est-ce que vous avez revu votre marque
et non pas depuis quelques temps
j'espère trouver pas négliger pour me
remplacer auprès d'alexis je suis très
touchée de tout ce que vous avez fait
pour moi pauline sûrs en aucun cas au
détriment de votre vie sentimentale ne
vous inquiétez pas de cela mais si je
vois la tête au contraire vous aussi
pauline vous avez droit au bonheur
marion ce qu'il ya on vous met météo s'y
plient commence à du mal que je vais
vous faire monsieur je vous estiment
trop si vous cachez davantage la vérité
et à la dignité
l'ex imminent sur tellement il est aussi
mais fort de continuer à vous abusez à
s'amuser
oui oui la lettre à nanning monté par
quoi je suis vraiment la maîtresse
d'avec sa non non non cette machine
serait dejabu doute le genou va pas
logique avec vous même vous le croyez
que vous citez pas fabien cibray vous le
croyez plus nous n'avons même pas pour
lui il est normal que nous ne mettrons
plus très bien on ne peut plus sain que
ce n'est pas en faisant l'autruche que
vous êtes un str et ce qui s'est passé à
votre avis qui prétendent être la
maîtresse d'alexis qu'est ce que c'est
leur est tellement extraordinaire je
suis plus jeune que vous et vous nous
avez pratiquement jeté dans les bras
l'un de l'autre
en tout cas on nous accuse en un temps
où l'on avait donné l'idée croyez le
point g scrupule à vous trahir mais j'ai
senti que lexie avait besoin nous ce
n'est pas en le traitant comme vous
l'avez fait un homme trouve son
épanouissement et pour adopter ce sont
deux franchises qui vous est si cher
j'ajouterai que vous ne l'avez pas volé
je n'aurais pas autant vous le dire
l'entente physique entre nous et au
talent oui
alexia les ardeurs de shannon comme s'il
avait beaucoup de retard et maintenant à
les y retrouver votre nature à une
sortie vos griffes
traitez-moi de tous les noms qu'est ce
que vous attendez un cri accès marie
votre famille et vos larmes que vous
avez de récupérer tout s'use la carte de
la douceur voulait tarir mamadou tu
m'appeler mariant avec ses bateaux dits
oui je lui ai tout dit
moi je ne vois pas du tout de quoi vous
voulez parler
il votera bien les filles non j'étais
sur mario kart haine qui unirait 12
septembre vous pouvez vous nommer
l'excellent et si tu aimes pour livrer
que nous aimons celle d'un prêt le
monument au contraire donc vous vous
aimez tous les deux et comme je vous
aime aussi jeune aucun prix être une
entrave à votre bonheur je vous donne ma
chance vous donne mon lit je vous donne
le divorce
tout est amour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je ne sais pas je ne tiens vraiment pas
la foire est trop sévère avec toi mon
chéri pensez-vous pauline les graves
manquait peut-être un peu de moyens
naples - le vous dites n'importe quand
quand avez-vous par des matelas mais la
télé n'en veut pas à l'accepter il
assoit notre oreille trame musicale
jouer de l'instrument en folie monsieur
un peu étudié le piano comme tout le
monde peut être pourriez vous
accompagnez alexis quand il répète en ce
serait à la fois qu'il est charmant
non mais je vois syndicat bectu diva
complètement telle communion entre deux
êtres qui font de la musique ensemble ça
va être comme un dialogue va pas de
dialogue secret je vois du violoncelle
pour moi c'est pour autre chose que le
passe temps d'un dimanche après midi
pluvieux à la con tu sais bien mal
étonnant si ce n'est pas un avion vous
voyez bien que quelqu'un paie qu'est ce
que vous faites là toutes les deux
coller à moi comme des mouches un bon
groupe et tout mon oxygène aller vaquer
ya de quoi s'occuper que diab dans une
maison en otage un énorme pouvant aller
au fond du jardin
selon ce qui lui fait encore un peu
chaud non non c'est moi qui vais me
retirer et en vous priant pauline de ne
pas me suivre si ce n'est pas pour me
demander si ma présence vous à gaz et à
lavaur autres pauline lamielle vous me
les cassent et toutes les deux
[Applaudissements]
vraiment épouse de calexico reatard
depuis votre retour l'islam n'a pas
parce que vous en faites injustement les
frères qui me rudoie moi c'est normal de
vieux époux mais vos pauline purro en
pleine lune de miel nous en trio telle
folie mois sur blessure le lay à quoi on
aurait pu moi j'ai toujours ma musique
une autre situation délicate en conviant
membres un dépanneur d'autres s'en sont
arrangés nathalie retour ici que depuis
quelques heures
laisser aux choses de temps le se
stabiliser de pourrir non je ne crois
pas qu'il y ait de place pour nous deux
sets mais si pauline avec beaucoup
d'amour aux y parviendrons je demandais
que m'effacer vous le savez bien
alexis refuse de me laisser partir par
pitié de moi même je ne suis pas de
celles qui sacre aux volumes du mois qui
le supplie de ne pas abandonner alex il
a besoin de vous j'assure seulement en
douce la transmission de pouvoir un peu
trop en douceur peut-être allez-vous
cela paul et part si je ne suis pas dupe
marion cette nouvelle attitude de votre
part n'a pour but que de me désarmé
commencer par contre une femme qui
s'écrase là se battre contre moi
ensuite est prête à faire parce que je
ne veux pas votre bonheur et celui
d'alexis non dans le tour nombre
pratiquement question des signes
religieux c'est ma petite folie voilà
bien une chose qu'on ne peut pas décider
moi en tout cas pas si longtemps vous
mad auriez peut-être les circonstances
sans fil et nous avons même bien en
europe tout de même non je préfère votre
mari ou que c'est gentil
excusez moi je vous tapez la pharma
chine pour aller couvrir une certain
qu'en plus vous taper à la machine
cela lui a rendu de grands services pour
sa correspondance d'air frais et bien
que vous voulez être indispensable
alimenter des fêtes un correspondant à
ce pourquoi ta planète au grand dialogue
avant ça on écoute j'aimerais bien te
voir sur le moment il est toujours temps
de ne pas qu'elle soit la pauvre je ne
sais pas mais ils tiennent de ces places
la nouvelle toute la plage jusqu'à ce
que je revienne moins cher oui mais tu
revenais line est rempli de qualités
physiques sur sèvre elle a beaucoup
peint belli et la lame de son visage au
support du tout reluisant mauvaise
conscience rien peu oui que tu attends
je te rappelle que je comprends très
bien tout ce qui s'est passé que je
n'accepte que je l'admets mieux que je
la proue droit est ta compréhension
plutôt que le papier est née autour des
mines est la chance qu'une jolie fille
sensible intelligente artiste ne tombe
dans les bras puisque c'est pas
merveilleux qu'un cherches tu as prouvé
que je préfère de beaucoup cette
solution là c'est tout de même plus
convenable c'était même plus pratique
pratique pour kiel pour toi mais
naturellement j'ai pu être surveillés
c'est pauline qu'ils veulent maintenant
vous n'êtes pas vraiment pas ce que tu
écoutes marion tout ça prend un tour qui
ne me plaît pas mais qui ne me plaît pas
du tout me kaltoum ses complices et de
noël chacun peut je ne sais pas pourquoi
mais je ne trouve pas ça très classe et
le mensonge des malpropres la
dissimulation pourquoi courir à lée
rendez vous clandestin comme pauline et
wa pouvez-vous voir librement ici vous
mettiez aussi senghor ocha ces frais
jugés et tour à hull en rollat ou non y
aller c'est pourquoi que s'attache tout
ce que je me dis que je suis sincèrement
si je suis un saumon et tout s'est très
bien d'ailleurs car normalement tu
devrais furieuse contre moi cracher le
feu me jeter la vaisselle à la tête
au lieu de ça madame donne sa
bénédiction c'est marion que moi je
deviens toi même la jalousie excessive
demeurer soir vous des bruitages pour me
faire plaisir une petite tâche vraiment
à nouveau jeudi c'est vrai vraiment
certainement la nuit de le refuser
mais j'ai beau essayer savent n'a pas
effectué le fait exprès pour me
contrarier parce qu'on va pour la
majorité puis de retrouver jusqu'à la
jeunesse et autant de douceur ça va si
mal est fait je lui dirai par
l'intéressé breezy tu es vraiment avec
ces récompenses par mathias est souvent
reproché maladie relance mon refus de
concession le feu des lésions que vous
faisait sur mes semblables
maintenant que je ne suis plus que
sourire et mansuétude tu me le reproche
aussi à l'excès de ces primes a vraiment
il est vraiment je me pose des questions
comment dois-je être pour te plaire eh
ben je ne sais pas je ne sais pas mais
je crois que je te préféré à vendre les
rassemblements d'éternels insatisfaits
j'ai pas encore embrassé néron depuis
morteau séparant il veut faire douter
mais au nez rond bon allez c'est promets
moi une chose qu'est ce que tu veux que
je te prends bien être
très très très très gentil avec pauline
sinon ça commence à bien faire le boulot
nadia et alexis je viens de parler notre
réponse aux japonais pour les festivals
et tokyo elle doit partir d'urgence
voulez vous l'aviez que j'aille vite la
poster franchement oui oui c'était
inutile et dois je vous rappeler
contraire à nos conventions bien quand
on est arrivé on m'a regardé droit dans
les yeux après qu'elle ait reçu cet
anonyme je n'ai pas eu le courage de
nier
lorsque vous ça vous aurait pas gêné de
continuer à mentir et dire que j'ai
envie et le bonheur de votre cou et
qu'il ne donnait que comme tant d'autres
cimentée par les mensonges et les
compromissions par quelque chose d'autre
la victime luis a du bon parfois la
betterave quelle lâcheté je vous offre
une chance de renouveau et vous reprenez
moyens de paiement à tout ça je vous
interdis traité ma femme ne viennent pas
tous flanc allez vous savez c'était
tenté de la quitter non c'est d'ailleurs
une de fois j'ai quitté mais je suis
revenu avant qu'elle ne s'en aperçoit
parce que je présume que je n'aime tout
simple vous fait chambre à part depuis
des années ça ne regarde
et puis vous savez malgré mon grand âge
j'aurais encore la force d'aller d'une
chambre à l'autre celle purement dire
mais seulement voilà est-ce que le coeur
vous en dit le qr ci fit il quand le
désir n'est plus là on vous dit
le désir est un phénomène imprévisible
mappy pauline il va il nous quitte
lorient pour qui beaucoup
nous ne posons pas toutes ces questions
alexis je sais que vous avez envie de
faire l'amour avec moi et pour moi il y
avait ce désir aux présentes
non non ce ne serait pas très commun
pour le mans on aimerait jouer nos
matches mais ce serait de la folie de
temps en temps pour un homme d'habitude
c'est doit être bon sinon oui mais pas
maintenant pas maintenant cette nuit
peut-être réussir aiment admirer le
magicien fu lee gc
voilà vous êtes satisfaite maintenant
c'est ce que nous cherchons à nous
envoyer mario fonds desjardins alors
vous ne savez pas marion est toujours
partout où c'est possible alors moi sa
voix ça me semble infiniment balala et
c'est moins cher il faut choisir entre
les remorques
peut-être peut-être enfin on n'est pas
obligé de sanvensa tous les membres
mince c'est de la provocation
je vais vous la cinéma votre rétro
chaponnay c'est décidé vous écrivez un
grand sioniste avec un sommet mardi
pourquoi s'en prendre 2 oui oui en
général
qu'est ce qui est étrange vous ne
mettiez qu'un seul avion ce n'est pas
l'habitude de faire des fautes
d'orthographe maintenant oui ça tout le
monde peut faire une erreur
d'inattention mais un lie à une curieuse
coïncidence avant quelle coïncidence
figurez-vous que l'auteur de la lettre
anonyme écrit aussi violoncelliste avec
un seul n c'est la preuve que c'est une
fois plus courantes que vous le
prétendez l2 aujourd'hui les figures
préciser votre pensée je vous prie elle
est encore à passer sous mac user
non je ne vous accuse parce qu'on vient
curieux s'étaient d'abord pouvoir et
j'écris des trains arrivent à marquer
mais oui pourquoi je maldonne renoue
renault vous ne vous demandez pas du
tout je sais très bien ce que vous
pensez en ce moment je ne pense jamais
un aussie vous dit que c'était le
meilleur moyen de mettre marion devant
le fait accompli que vous obliger à
choisir entre elle et moi un vrai
bonheur je suis très loin de penser
enfin je vous ferai remarquer que c'est
vous qui vous accusez pour le moment
c'est pas moi l'huile est unanime c'est
ce qu'il ya de plus vil
mais j'ai beau chercher facilement faut
bien qu'elle avait écrit dans votre
esprit salut peut-être que moi à
lessines euros mois que j'ai vu tout
dans cette maison de nous je sais que tu
meures à la défense banlieue n'ont pas
de drone surtout pas d'autres
enfin s'aligner à face avant très je
vous en prie vous iriez vous emplit
alors dans quel état vous nous avez
ramené transformé oui mais ses chéquiers
des dates à faire à l'envers quoi
peyton et je l'entends carrie vous allez
pouvoir juger vous même mais mais c'est
mon petit 15 nov chéri plaisir ça me
fait d'avoir votre bonne bouille à lens
est allé trois fois comme à la campagne
j'obtiens des morts maudite eh oui on
l'avait dit faire c'est son nom vous
serez un loukoum je suis aluko enfin
vous êtes surtout quand je pensais
vraiment le voulais je me disais dommage
qu'elle ne soit pas là une bonne petite
prise de mettre sa miss france 2010 et a
comme hervé fans ne vont pas trop vous
manqué avec sale éprouvent déjà comme
une nostalgie remettez votre place et
elle a douché quand on est paré mois à
près de vous nous avons un prolongement
d'épidémie de fièvre aphteuse donc des
parts à vous être sur les genoux patrol
vehicle pour volonté on avait besoin
parce qu'en plus il me tend bun de suite
oui langage peut faire quelque chose
pour vos 15 à ma femme veut revenir
vivre avec moi mais c'est merveilleux
au contraire on sait plus où aller oui
son dernier type des marcheurs un
appareil ménager qui avait tourné la
tête en lui faisant la démonstration de
l'inspirateur a dû l'appliquer comme les
autres il est normal qu'elle s'est
tournée vers vous après l'avoir cocufié
avec la terre entière justement elle
peut faire la comparaison
et c'est vous qu'elle préfère et bien
moi je trouve ça plutôt flatteur vous
entendez sommes chez brute que c'est un
point de vue
qu'est ce que vous feriez vous à
l'implant et pardonnerait c'est si bon
de pardonner pardonner cas slave
pardonner évidemment je me dis qu'il ya
des gosses non feinte ou
après tout ce qu'elle m'a fait pas tout
cela n'est pas grave
laisser les petits trots qu'une tombe et
de la com les fleurs de prunier qui ne
porte pas le fruit secoué le premier
cazenave ça tout est le premier je vois
pas le rapport
nous avons tous un premier en nous oui
oui ma femme avait couvert les finances
en france où j'ai appris à bien nous
connaître grâce à eux donc à mieux
comprendre les américains des femmes
on m'avait prévenue mais tout de même
bon eh ben je lèche coûts et le prunier
il que vous me dites qu'il faut secouer
le premier vous en repartirait pas si
vous avez des doutes wallemme trouver
nous en reparlerons bien vous attendez
le du rhum les jeux mais les voici qui
arrive novembre à bord ce qui nous amène
ici moi qui leur ai téléphoné pour leur
faire mes excuses
il arrive tard d'un second report en
cuisine absolument charmant chers amis
votre vie pleurotes et de juin et je
vous remercie du fond du coeur d'avoir
six titres et podiums elle appelait on
va vous savez nous on n'aime pas les
brouilles j'ai tendance à être aussi
c'est manger est épouvantable comme ça
marche bien je dois le reconnaître il
était souffrant
nous à terre oui oui un quart du temps
après votre passage au moulin on
hospitalise ma femme
ah ben voilà qui explique tout vent
comme ça toutes mes excuses pour savoir
si mal reçue oh je veux que nous soyons
amis allez on n'en parle plus et si on
se connaît simon la maniaque prix cassés
par proches
j'aime bien qu'on apprécie ce que
j'offre un changement apprécié gens
prennent souvent elle avait le nom s'est
arrêtée en passant attendre d asseoir
même si ces minutes alors nous allons
peut être il ya un cocktail et
commencent à dire que vous ne soyez pas
invité vous n'êtes donc pas membres du
club mon choix c'est si agréable de se
retrouver entre gens du même avis mais
les assurances m'interdise révolte mon
poignet mais oui bien sûr esclave de
mettre un ravissant cet ensemble
ravissant vous trouvez
d'acheter me 3 fois et j'en suis déjà
fatigués mais quand on pense qu'à ça
coûterait une brave toutou même est
raisonnable un régime ou quoi wow vous
prendrait pour votre fils mecha mélange
que je m'étais pas fait dix ans qu'on
marion que d'être aimable n'était pas
seul package
et donc georgina quand est ce qu'ils
viennent casser la graine si on ouvrait
une boîte de foie gras base un tabou
mais c'est un cadeau du ciel
alors on compte sur moi si jamais
d'aussi casnav jouant au poker d'accord
si je n'ai pas d'urgence et sincèrement
que jeunes femmes que nous avons
rencontrées ici la dernière fois s'il
est on tenté contre il faut absolument
nous là on elle est toujours là vous
pensez à propos la disparue savez vous
que je suis jalouse de votre clown à
balard tu as vu tes dires la mienne est
un tapis pour envoyer autant nous avons
deux jardiniers des étrangers il faut
dire et qui se la coule tous ces gens là
viennent chez salah branchages et autres
déchets pour les médias qui ne va pas
aller j'ai peur il a fait une bêtise
encore oui mais enfin qu'est ce que
j'attends qu'ils ne va plus à vous
plaisir à les contourner
c'est pas encore pour cette fois on se
demande est ce que vous faisiez vous
assurez vous une idée par l'entrée de
m'ouvrir les rênes m
donc j'aimerais faire mes adieux à
marion vous avez un oeil c'est quand je
pars accordé le moment c'est désolant
oui l'espoir justement nos amis pour
réclamer les soldes plaisir inattendu
leur pari zouzou surtout demain soir
qu'on lui dit et il n'y a pas que c'est
à dire alors vous venez c'est tout pour
pouvoir vous baigner la piscine vous
attend non ce sera pour une autre fois
malheureusement je rentre à paris ce
soir à lockheed et pauline premier à
nouvelle wii mario jeté là être là pour
vous accueillir
maintenant s'il t'a fait rassuré sur
votre état il est grand temps que je
libère votre unique chambre d'amis plein
dans la police depuis trop longtemps
mais s'il ya que ça à la pommeraye on a
de quoi vous loger il nous vous l'avons
dit dédié moi nous aimons beaucoup
recevoir justement nous avons une bande
de copains très marrant qui viennent
dans ce prochain week-end alors 6 à 8
ans elle revient coter une dit pas non
on va cela dépendra de mon programme de
travail je dois interviewé omar sharif
mais là on fera un bridge
je peux vous téléphonique dans le
courant de la semaine mais bien sûr il
ya chez moi que les bruyères de chauffe
nous attendons des amis pour le prochain
week-end et le suivant aussi à l'aise
par marion on me donnait pas nous en
vouloir de vous l'enlevez les ferrand
avérés mais vous verrez
pauline est l'invité idéal le visiter
votre propriété vous avez dû arranger
cela ira ghoul s'est un peu haut c'est
mon mari n'aime que la haute époque
j'adore d'éviter oui mais avec une
touche de design franchement les 1000 m2
soit encore fait c'est exactement le
théâtre dans lequel je vous imaginez
quelques maires veuillez vous former
tous les deux fait des bulles comme une
complicité entre vous deux quand on vous
voit ensemble on s'est dit il n'ya rien
de plus réconfortant que le spectacle de
brasseurs d'affaires qui a forgé son
destin et sa compagne qui partage sa
réussite
cela vous rend confiance dans le genre
humain et vous réconcilie avec bien des
choses graves en commun bravo eric oget
tout mois soit pas plus mais quand même
le culot de revenu chez moi devant moi
aller mais rossi outrecuidant un couple
merveilleux ces deux caricatures
à tous des [ __ ] c'est tous des
hypocrites êtes des concurrents
j'ai vu
show mêlant de plaisir aux plus basses
la gournerie insultes ou messieurs dames
et richard pour les moches madame votre
robe elle est moche et pour dépensant
des millions voudrait un moins gros
derrière le pdg dans le ferons si le
prêteur du karité plus perdu mais parmi
ses sept tours jusqu'à ce que vit le
redis responsable si vous saviez ce que
j'ai sous son mari et à la provençale et
ça donne un petit patrick enfin pas trop
loin trop loin
peut-être croyez que ça allait se passer
comme ça ça paraît tout à l'heure tous
les deux mots banane
boules quand tu fais et vous
j'invite les vieux bien georgina
quittons cette maison de singles et
georgina george aurait plutôt que tout
le monde
mais quand fermé avec vous et bien
georgette qu'est ce qui se passe mais
tombée d'un petit caca 340 interne et de
pensée
et parce qu'ils ont su avec johnny
hallyday prépare à tirer sur des pigeons
mais sûrement fait ce carton atacama
remet ça va vous mener hors de chez moi
de choc très belle eva vous l'aurez la
vienne jusqu'à 3 argent public pas plus
que lui convalescent
quand elle va devenir elle-même c'est
tout de suite plus la trahir millions de
tonnes mon sac de voyage ne tient pas
m'attarder savent aussi bien des fois je
trouve le plus grand chose at war de
nous tout est très bien calculé pour
tendre l'accident de voiture votre
dévotion pour moi le suicide raté ça ne
vous inquiète pas de taille
mais qu'est ce que vous imaginez que mon
ambition c'est de prendre votre place
avait tout pour en tout cas
ces trois chroniques qu'est ce que j'en
ai à [ __ ] moi d'alexis bricaire
excusez moi d'intervenir mais vous
n'avez pas toujours des choix que vous
vous prenez pour un séducteur
on nous regarde et vous êtes et ce thème
voulait plus mais vous devez comprendre
comment 19 par kraft à l'excès mais le
ton change je suis un homme plus jeune à
sa bouche alors vous ne vous adorez
temps je pense que j'ai gâché mon été à
faire la boniche pour ses deux reins
gains on est dans les rangs des biens
crds par alexis c'est dur 1 la ménopause
retour sur la chaîne
les vulgaires et permettant des bulls
est bien fait là pour le look bobo et le
ton chant pacotille je vous abandonne à
vos ébats amoureux
qu'est ce que les méchantes dit non tu
veux pas lâcher ma place tout accomplir
la fantasia est terminée ce qui fera du
cloud allez encore dire que si vos
enfants à mon pauvre vous inquiétez pas
j'ai pu te défonces suis pas bon je vous
laisse avons plus de coach
je pense que de mes 20 ans pour voir si
vous êtes entier tous les deux marion
marché des petites amies dont j'avais
tout expliquer qu'ils t'ont égoïste à
l'acheter je les connais par coeur et
ils viendront donner une fois plus une
démonstration éclatante mais qu'est ce
que tu veux je suis un artiste aux
journées pas d'habitude de vivre sol du
monde qui est tellement été une belle
année
oui mais je tombe à rien facile et je
tiens à rester je comptais tellement sur
toi pour me débarrasser de pauline alors
j'imagine la panique quand tu te disait
prête à diverses primes accrue et là
j'ai joué mon personnage aussi longtemps
que j'ai pu avec un tempérament comme
d'amis acheta sûr que ça a été dur tu as
tout le temps jouer la comédie de n'a
jamais été sa série des forces et de
lettres ne veux tu que je te dise
labonté c'est une solution ne paraisse
avec tu sais que j'ai marché mais nous
avons tous marchent à pauline je vais
surprendre le début je l'aimé bien moi
pauline c'est elle qui m'a eue pense que
tu ne regardes une authentique une
calculer ses paroles mielleuses bien
j'aurais dit condamner plus longtemps à
sa gentillesse il sait très bien il n'y
a jamais que toi je m'en vais te serrer
la vis moi c'est d'ailleurs c'est comme
ça que tu me veux une tortionnaire à la
schlague qui va marcher à la chine
ah ben tiens je te retrouves je te
retrouve enfin celle de masse à vide en
apportant tu as des nouvelles de
christian py renom christian kjaer les
questions perlot son irrésistible petit
nostra il réside et l'anjou pas exagérer
que la guerre résiste à ce qu'il
paraisse plus de traîner semafo tu me
disais que c'était un tel combat
oui si on perd je m'en vais te lui quand
cela colle mais tu es jaloux
ma parole mon mari jaloux
soyez béni pour line laver dans ce
couvent à une ossature elle perd là
combien de temps l'icsi que tu ne m'as
pas prise dans ses bras
je ne sais pas pourquoi me demande tout
ça et bien moi je sais une éternité
donc ça j'écoute mais c'est toi qui
disais toujours qu'à partir d'un certain
âge de diffusion pour y devenir gênante
embarrasse n'ai jamais dit que nous
avions atteint cet âge que de toute
façon je me trompais quand on s'aime
vraiment rien l'événement si seulement
tu pouvais être un peu moins et si mon
amour si seulement tu pouvais être un
peu plus enfin le voile a délivré le
pauline et tout rentrait dans l'ordre
dans fond c'est une chose que l'effet
lagarde d'envoyer ses produits c'est
pourquoi l'étude statuer sur cette aile
c'est rageant violoncelliste avec un
seul à mon dieu ça a perdu la power ça
doit tout de même jamais et bien jamais
d'un cloud capable d'une chose par le
maladroit cartables et de pire la nature
en l'occurrence lettre anonyme moi qui
l'eût cru
lettres anonymes à la lehman à nîmes pas
vraiment puis je pas l'habitude de me
signer les lettres que je m'envoie
teboul et la photo là c'était un petit
détail de raffinement peau douce h
la caisse que nous avons eu la joie
d'interpréter devant vous ce soir et de
messieurs barillet et grédy
[Applaudissements]
ceret la mise en place de monsieur yves
lalonde
[Applaudissements]
avec la mise en scène de jacques charon
avec henri poirier
eh bien nous sommes
[Applaudissements]
ah oui il ira
ouais pasquali
[Applaudissements]
les permis
non bretonnière
et sa fille et barret
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]